BY I'M THE VETERAN AFFAIRS.
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
SECRETARY OF STATE. IN THE FAIR
CREEL FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION.
WE ROLL CALL THE STEPS QUORUM
PLEASE.
COOPER HERE BRO.
HOW LARA? CHIU HERE CHOI.
THROUGH A QUORUM.
SAY WE'VE NUMBER OF ITEMS ON
THE VOTE ONLY CHALLONER FIRST
TAKE UP ISSUES FOR THE SECRETARY
OF STATE. FOR POLITICAL PRACTICE
COMMISSION PART OF AIRLINE
FARES.
PUBLIC CONSUMER AFFAIRS YOU'LL
BE ISSUES ONE THROUGH FOUR SIX
THROUGH EIGHT. ELEVEN THROUGH
TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY EIGHT.
DOUBLE MOTION TO APPROVE THESE
ITEMS AS BUDGETED.
ALSO GONNA.
COOPER. AYE GROW CABALLERO CHIU
CHOI.
PHYSICALLY ABLE TO GET THE
FOLLOWING ISSUES INDIVIDUALLY
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE FOR THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION.
DRIVE MOTION TO APPROVE THIS
ITEM IS BUDGETED.
A SECOND THAT.
COOPER I BROKE CAVALERA CHIU.
CHOI.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE FOR THE PART
OF THE VETERAN AFFAIRS NEVER
MOTION APPROVE THIS ITEM IS
BUDGET SOME OF.
SECOND.
COOPER I BROKE CABALLERO CHIU.
CHOI.
ISSUE NUMBER TEN FOR DEPARTMENT
OF VETERAN AFFAIRS NOT A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
SECOND.
COOPER I BROKE CABALLERO CHIU.
CHOI.
AND FINALLY WILL TAKE UP ISSUES
TWENTY SEVEN FOR THE PART OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. IS OUR MOTION
TO PRODUCES BUDGET.
SO.
COOPER I BROKE CAVALERA CHIU.
CHOI.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE A SECRETARY OF
STATE. A VOTING SYSTEM
REPLACEMENT FOR COUNTIES
PLEASE PROCEED.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
PERSON COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
I'M SUSAN LAPSLEY DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF STATE FIRST
SECRETARY ALEX SEPARATE STATE
ALEX PADILLA. AND I'M HERE TODAY
TO ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE SECTOR A STATE BUDGET ITEM
WHICH PROVIDES A HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
FOR THE REPLACEMENT OF VOTING
SYSTEMS FOR COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BUDGET
ALLOCATION.
IS AN ESSENTIAL ENTIRELY
INVESTMENT IN OUR DEMOCRACY
AGING VOTING SYSTEMS ARE ONE OF
THE GREATEST THREATS TO THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS
TODAY.
THE VOTING TECHNOLOGY IN USE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S AT IS AT
OR NEARING END OF LIFE ELECTION
OFFICIALS IN THE STATE CANNOT
GET REPLACEMENT PARTS.
FOR ELECTION EQUIPMENT MANY OF
THE SYSTEMS ARE FUNCTIONING ON
OUT OF DATE OPERATING SYSTEMS
WITH KNOWN SECURITY RISKS.
THE DUE DILIGENCE AND UPKEEP AN
OF KEEPING THESE AGING SYSTEMS
LIKE DEDICATED ELECTION
OFFICIALS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAS HELPED TO REDUCE THE RISK
MANY OF THEM YOU'LL HEAR FROM
TODAY.
THE PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES
INCLUDING THE STRICT. AND
STRENUOUS TESTING THAT WE'VE
DONE. BY THE STATE HAVE ALSO TO
HELP MINIMIZE THIS RISK.
BUT CALIFORNIA'S MODERNIZE OUR
VOTING EQUIPMENT FOR FUTURE
ELECTIONS
THE URGENT NEED TO REPLACE OUR
VOTING SYSTEMS IS NOT A NEW
ISSUE.
AS EARLY AS TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
BIPARTISAN COMMISSION ON
ELECTION ADMINISTRATION ISSUED A
REPORT.
I HAD BEEN AND THE REPORTS.
WARNED OF THE AGING EQUIPMENT
AND THAT.
THE BENCH.
THE IMPENDING CRISIS IN VOTING
TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS ABOUT TO HIT
THE COUNTRY.
IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
NEW YORK'S UNIVERSITIES UNIQUE
NEW YORKERS OVERSEAS FRIENDS
CENTER FOR JUSTICE ISSUED A
REPORT THAT RAISE CONCERNS
INCLUDING THE FAILURE OF
EQUIPMENT.
TO WORK AS INTENDED AND THE
DIFFICULTY FINDING REPLACEMENT
PARTS FOR MACHINES THEY'RE NO
LONGER MANUFACTURED NO LONGER
MANUFACTURED.
AND JUST LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
REPORTED SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF A
CATASTROPHIC FAILURE OF AGING
VOTING SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES.
I PERSONALLY CLEARLY REMEMBER
THE TWO THOUSAND PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION THE CONCLUDED WITH THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT'S OF
SETTLING THE BUSH V. GORE LEGAL
BATTLE.
HANGING CHADS AND BUTTERFLY
BALLOTS THAT WAS MY FIRST
ELECTION IS AHEAD OF ELECTIONS
INVALID AND IT WAS QUITE STE.
QUITE INTERESTING AND QUITE FUN
WITH A LOT OF INTERESTING
ISSUES.
BUT MANY BELIEVE THAT THOSE
ISSUES WERE CREATED BY THE AGING
VOTING SYSTEMS AND FOR IN
FLORIDA.
IN RESPONSE TO THAT CONGRESS
ACTED IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER TO
PASS THE HELP AMERICA VOTE ACT
THE PROVIDED FUNDING TO
MODERNIZE VOTING SYSTEMS IN ALL
FIFTY STATES.
THAT SAME YEAR CALIFORNIAN
LEGISLATURE PLACEPROP FORTY ONE
ON THE TWO THOUSAND TWO BALLOT
WHICH PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR STATE VOTING
SYSTEMS.
THAT WAS MORE THAN FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO AND WE'RE BACK WHERE WE
STARTED WITH AGING VOTING
SYSTEMS THAT MAY FAIL.
THE COUNTY VOTING MACHINES ARE
FALLING APART INVENTORS NO
LONGER MAKE REPLACEMENT PARTS
COUNTIES TURN FREQUENTLY WHICH
I'M SURE THEY'LL TELL YOU ABOUT.
TO EBAY. AND LOOK FOR SCRAP
PARTS FROM OTHER STATES TO KEEP
THE MACHINES GOING.
SOME COUNTIES OPERATE ON
OPERATING SYSTEMS ARE SO OLD
DEFENDER LONG LONG NO LONGER
PROVIDES TECH SUPPORT MEANING
SOME COUNTY.
CALIFORNIA VOTING MACHINES
CANNOT BE PATCH UPDATED WITH THE
LATER CYBERSECURITY SOFTWARE.
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES ALONE CANNOT
BEAR THE FINANCIAL BURDEN OF
PURCHASING THE NEW SYSTEMS THEY
NEED HELP. AND THEY NEED OUR
HELP FROM THE STATE'S.
WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITY TO
MODERNIZE OUR VOTING EQUIPMENT
TO ENSURE THAT THE SECURITY OF
ELECTIONS.
TO EXPAND VOTING OPPORTUNITIES
AND TO IMPROVE DISABILITY AND
LANGUAGE ACCESS
BY INCLUDING THIS ITEM IN THE
BUDGET THE LEGISLATURE WILL
CLEARLY ILLUSTRATE THEIR
UNDERSTANDING THAT INVESTMENT IN
VOTING SYSTEMS. IS INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
AND THE HEALTH OF OUR DEMOCRACY
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT AND STATE INVESTMENT NEW
VOTING SYSTEMS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ELLIOTT.
A CAROLINGIAN LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
GIVEN THE CONDITION OF THE
VOTING SYSTEMS I AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL WE DO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ARE PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO COUNTIES. OFF FOR
PURCHASING NEW VOTING EQUIPMENT.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
DISTRIBUTING THIS FUNDING. BASED
ON THE COST COUNTIES WOULD INCUR
FIVE TO IMPLEMENT THE SP FOUR
FIFTY MODEL OR THE VOTE CENTER
MONO WHICH WAS.
A BILL PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO
TO PERK UP OPEN VOTE CENTERS FOR
LONGER DURATIONS OF TIME THAT
THERE ARE FEWER OF THEM RELATIVE
TO THE PRECINCT MODEL. WE WOULD
NOT RECOMMEND REQUIRING.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF US BEFORE
FIFTY DUE TO THE.
NATURE OF THE VOTING SYSTEMS AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL BUT THAT
DISTURBING THE FUNDING IN THIS
METHOD WOULD PROVIDE SOME
INCENTIVES FOR COUNTIES TO MOVE
TO THIS. UP METHOD OF VOTING.
FINANCE.
JOHN FITZPATRICK DEPARTMENT OF
JUST A SMALL NOTE THAT THE. WAY
THE FUNDING IS PROJECTED TO BE
DISTRIBUTED AT THIS TIME.
PROVIDES AN INCENTIVE FOR EACH
COUNTY TO MOVE TO THE VOTE
CENTER MODEL AS THE COSTS THE
LOWER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
MODEL. ARE WHAT.
OUR PROJECT WHERE THE AMOUNTS
PROJECTED BY ON A COUNTY BY
COUNTY BASIS.
THANK YOU. OF QUESTIONS THE
PROPOSED LEVEL FUNDING ADEQUATE
FOR ALL COUNTIES.
REPLACE OUR VOTING SYSTEMS.
AND WHAT IS THE BASIS THAT
DETERMINATION OF I HEAR FROM
THE.
ACTORS TING FINANCE ON THAT.
RIGHT SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
FINANCING IS.
AND HOW WE GOT THERE IT IS I
REQUEST FOR.
A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION
WELL OVER A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
MILLION AND REQUIRES A FIFTY
FIFTY MATCH THE WAY THAT WE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE ARRIVED AT
THIS NUMBER.
WITH OVER THE YEARS WE'VE TAKEN
A LOOK AND ANALYZE FOR EACH OF
THE COUNTIES THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES CALIFORNIA WHAT WOULD
IT TAKE IF THEY WERE IN A
POLLING PLACE MODEL TO HAVE TO
REPLACE THE. PRECINCT COUNTERS
THERE'S CENTRAL COUNT ALL THE
MIX ALL THE EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
WOULD NEED INCREASING MODEL. WE
THEN TOOK AND THAT THAT'S WHERE
THE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
THAT YOU GUYS SAW IN AB SIX SIX
H. THAT FIGURE COMES UP AND I'M
SURE YOU'VE SEEN IT IN. ELIADES
REPORTS IN IN OTHER PLACES.
THIS REQUEST RIGHT HERE HAVE
TAKES
THE. US FIFTY COUNTIES AND
ASSUMES THAT ANY COUNTY THAT'S
FIFTY PERCENT OR LESS WILL STAY
WITHIN A BEEN A TRADITIONAL
POINT PLACE MODEL. IN THE ANY
COUNTY OVER FIFTY TWO PRECINCTS
WILL GO TO A VOTE CENTER MODEL
SO WHAT PERSONS THE COUNTIES ARE
OVER FIFTY AND.
IT'S. I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
PERCENTAGE I COULD SAY I GIVE
YOU JUST A REGULAR RUN OFF THE
LIST OF THE ONES THAT WOULD BE
UNDER FIFTY FOR YOU TO GIVE AN
IDEA OUR FOLLOW UP AFTER THIS
HAD.
THIS MEETING JUST TO GIVE THE
RUNDOWN OF IT THIS WAY SO THE
ONES THAT ARE GREATER THAN FIFTY
PRECINCTS WOULD BE OUR SOON TO
BE IN A. A VOTE CENTER MODEL SO
THERE'S.
SAVINGS A REALIZE THE EQUIPMENT
IS DIFFERENT THERE'S NOT AS MANY
PRECINCT BASS COUNTERS IT'S
MOSTLY YOUR CENTRAL COUNTY OF
OTHER EQUIPMENT THAT'S INVOLVED
WHICH IS.
PULL BOOKS AND BALLOT ON
DEMAND SO THIS FIGURE THE ONE
THIRTY FOUR. IS TAKES THAT.
STRUCTURE AND PUTS IN PLACE AND
HASA FIFTY FIFTY FIFTY MATCH BY
THE COUNTIES.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT IS ITS
VISION.
SUFFICIENT FOR WHAT THIS MODEL
IDIOTS
WHICH IS.
LESS THAN FIFTY PRECINCTS
RIGHT BASED THEY WITHIN A
TRADITIONAL POINT PLACE MODEL
GREATER THAN FIFTY PRECINCTS
THERE IN A BOAT CENTER MODEL
THAT'S WHAT GETS AT TAUGHT WHAT
JOHN WAS SAYING THAT. THE
INCENTIVE TO GO TO A VOTE CENTER
IS THE.
EFFICIENCIES THAT YOU'LL REAL
THAT I COUNTY WOULD REALIZE IN
GOING TO THAT AND THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO FUND THE MAJORITY OF
THEIR COSTS VERSUS STAYING IN A
TRADITIONAL POLLING PLACE.
A MODEL FOR THAT HELP YES.
JUST ILLEGAL COMMENTS ON THAT WE
THINK ABOUT THAT RESPONSE.
BUT SO WHERE WERE FAMILIAR WITH
HOW THE NUMBER WAS.
DETERMINED IN THIS ASSUMES AS
WAS ALREADY NOTED A FIFTY FIFTY
MATCH IN THE PAST.
A FOR INSTANCE WHEN THE STATE
ARE PASSED A BOND MEASURE TO I
PURCHASE VOTING EQUIPMENT FOR
COUNTIES IT WAS A THREE TO ONE
MATCH WHERE THE BOND MONIES
COVERED. A THREE QUARTERS OF THE
VOTING SYSTEMS COSTS.
AT THE OTHER I A POINT I'LL JUST
AYE REINFORCES THAT ANY COUNTIES
THAT OPS TO. A RETAINER MAC
CONTINUE THE PRECINCT MODEL WILL
INCUR COSTS ABOVE.
WHAT IS ESTIMATED IN THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET ITEM?
THE QUESTION THE COMMITTEE.
STRUCTURE I GIVE US CHAIR ONA
FOLLOW UP ON SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE CHAIR WAS
JUST ASKING
SO.
.
ASSUMING THE FIFTY FIFTY MATCH
ARE YOU THEN ASSUMING THAT THE
LOCALS WILL BE ABLE TO DO THEIR
PART OF THAT THE MATCH.
WITHIN THERE'S YES THAT THEIR
ASSUMPTION THAT THE COUNTIES
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO THE FIFTY
FIFTY MATCH AND WOULD THEY BE
BUYING THEIR EQUIPMENT TO
RELEASING THEIR EQUIPMENT SO THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL CONTEMPLATES
THAT WOULD BE EITHER. BUYING OR
PURCHASE OR LEASING.
AND.
.
I NO IN RECENT YEARS ARE BEEN A
NUMBER OF CHANGES TO ELECTION
LAW THAT CHANGES HOW COUNTIES
ADMINISTER ELECTIONS ARE. A WITH
THESE NEW REQUIREMENTS WILL HE
COUNTY BE ABLE TO KEEP UP. GIVEN
THE LEVEL OF FUNDING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
I THINK THAT THAT THE PROPOSAL
ON THE ANALYSIS THAT WE DID ON
THE COST CONTEMPLATE THE CHANGES
THE EVIL BOOKS THAT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD THAT COUNTIES. I WILL BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT WITH THEM THE
FUNDING.
CHIEF ABOLISH ABOUT THAT.
I FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
ARM.
I ALONG WITH SEVERAL OTHER
LEGISLATORS WE BELIEVE THAT.
THAT IT MAKES SENSE FOR US AS A
STATE TO LOOK AT A PUBLICLY
OWNED OPEN SOURCE VOTING SYSTEM.
I THINK THERE ARE MANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO BELIEVE THAT
SUCH A SYSTEM COULD HELP SAVE
THE STATE AS WELL AS COUNTIES.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
RESOURCES AND I KNOW THERE IS A
PROPOSAL FOR.
ANYWHERE FROM EIGHT TO TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR A MATCHING PROGRAM
TO DEVELOP. AN OPEN SOURCE
SYSTEM THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE
FOR EVERY COUNTY TO USE.
AND THERE ELECTIONS AND
WONDERING IF YOU GUYS HAVE ANY
INITIAL REACTIONS OUR THOUGHTS
TO.
THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE FLOATING
AROUND ON THIS.
I'LL GIVE YOU MY THOUGHTS I HAD
IN MY BEHALF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE I THINK.
SECTOR STATE HAS BEEN A. A BIG
SUPPORTER OF OPEN SOURCE VOTING
A WE. HAVE BEEN WATCHING CLOSELY
WITH EXCITEMENT WHAT LA IS DOING
WITH THEIR VISA PROD PROJECT.
HAVE HAD MANY COMMUNICATIONS
WITH SAN FRANCISCO AND WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT FORWARDS IN
DOING WITH THAT WITH AN OPEN
SOURCE. SYSTEMS THE SECRETARY
SUPPORTS OPEN SOURCE VOTING.
HAS BEEN THREE SIXTY BUT IT
IMPLEMENTED IN AND SPIT MAKE
PROVISIONS FOR OPEN SOURCE
VOTING WHICH PUTS BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN I THINK WAS.
A.
OF TIME SENATE'S.
PRETTY ISN'T IT A PITY AS BILL
SPONSORED SAM WE'VE ALSO BEGAN
TO WORKING CLOSE WITH LA TWO
INCH TO HELP THEM GET THEIR
SYSTEM. TESTED WHICH JUST
STARTED TESTING THAT THERE HAD
CENTRAL COUNT SYSTEM AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT. WHAT
COMES OUT OF THAT?
PALM AND THEN. ARE YOU ASSUMING
THEN THAT NOTHING THIS BUDGET
THOUGH. MOVES IN THAT DIRECTION
RIGHT.
AT THIS MOMENT
IT IS.
IT IT DEAD TELL ME WOULD EXPLAIN
IT BY A PHASER MONEY IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THAT WOULD MOVE
FORWARD A AN OPEN SOURCE VOTING
SYSTEM.
THEY'RE IN THIS IT'S IT'S
OPEN ENDED IT DOESN'T SAY WHAT
TYPE OF SYSTEM ARE NOT IT I
WOULD ANTICIPATE THAT.
AND THERE'S NO LIMITATION ON IT
SO I WOULD ANTICIPATE FOR
EXAMPLE THAT IF.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WANTED TO
GET REIMBURSED FOR THAT
EXPENDITURES THAT THEY'VE MADE
IN.
AND IT CREATING THEIR BE SAP
HAD VOTING SYSTEM THAT THIS
WOULD BE REIMBURSABLE THROUGH
THIS FUND OKAY AND AND AND WOOD.
WOULD YOUR AGENCY BE OPEN TO
SOME SORT OF MATCHING PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY TO COUNTIES TO HELP
DEVELOP.
AN OPEN SOURCE SYSTEM WILL BE
OPEN TO ANY CONSIDERATION.
I APPRECIATE THAT I CERTAINLY
KNOW SPEAKING FOR FOR MY CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO WE'VE LEAST A
SYSTEM SENSE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND ARE
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE ESTIMATING
THAT THE SYSTEM IS LIKELY TO BE
OBSOLETE
BY TWENTY TWENTY SO THIS IS
CERTAINLY. HAS EMERGENCY FOR FOR
MY COUNTY.
BUT I ALSO KNOW I THINK THE
IDEA OF AN OPEN SOURCE SYSTEM IS
ONE THAT HAS. A LOT OF APPEAL
FOR A LOT OF REASONS FROM A
FISCAL STANDPOINT FROM A
SECURITY STANDPOINT FROM A. UP
FROM A FROM A TRANSPARENCY
STANDPOINT SO CERTAINLY
SOMETHING I'M INTERESTED IN AND
AND WORKING ON AND I KNOW I'VE
HAD A BRIEF CONVERSATION WITH
THE SECRETARY ABOUT A. A ABOUT
HOUSE MS FOURTEEN BUCKS FOR I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT
ABSOLUTELY DO ANY COMMENTS ON
THAT.
SO I SEE THAT YOU LOOK LIKE YOU
WANTED TO SAY SOMETHING I DO BUT
NOT ON THAT AWAIT OKAY.
ILIO OR DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THE IDEA OF AN OPEN
SOURCE SYSTEM.
AND NOT SPECIFICALLY TO AN OPEN
SOURCE SYSTEM WE'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING RELATIVELY CLOSELY
WHAT.
LOS ANGELES HAS BEEN DOING
WHERE LESS MOTOR WITH SAN
FRANCISCO BUT. TO THE EXTENT
THAT COUNTIES ARE ABLE TO
DEVELOP THESE SYSTEMS.
.
AND GET THEM APPROVED THROUGH
THE SECRETARY SEE IS PERFECTLY
REASONABLE FOR THE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGE THE DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU.
LOOK UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
SORRY MISTER CHAIR FROM A VOTE
BY A ROUGH COUNT HERE YOU'D
ASKED HOW MANY OF THE COUNTIES
ARE GOING TO BE CONSIDERED SMALL
COUNTIES FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THIS PROPOSAL. IT'S ABOUT A
QUARTER OF THOSE COUNTIES WHICH.
CHARACTERIZED AS HAVING FIFTY
PRECINCTS OR FEWER. AND OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE THE CHOICE BETWEEN VOTE
CENTER OR POLLING PLACE FOR
THOSE SMALLER COUNTIES. IS NOT
MATERIALLY DIFFERENT THEM THE
ECONOMIES OF SCALE ASSOCIATED
WITH CONSOLIDATING DOESN'T APPLY
TO THE SAME DEGREE FOR THOSE
SMALLER COUNTIES.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO DEVELOP A
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S RIGHT NOW OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
WELL DOCTOR CHOI.
I WONDER IF YOU ARE AIMING FOR
THIS
I YEAR ELECTION.
SEVENFOLD THIS A NEW MACHINES.
I THINK IT WILL BE THAT WOULD BE
OUR HOPE AND OUR GOAL IF THE IF
IT'S.
APPROVED THEN WE MOVE FORGET TO
ENTER INTO CONTRACTS WITH THE
COUNTY YOU ALREADY PRE SELECTED
THE SYSTEM WHICH SYSTEMS SO IS A
POPULAR OR NOT COUNTY SO. FAR IN
THE STATE TO HAVE TO USE THE
SAME KIND OF MACHINE NO SO WE
WOULD IT UNDER THE ELECTION CODE
WE LEAVE IT UP TO STILL UP TO
THE COUNTIES AND WE THE SECTOR
SHE WOULD ANTICIPATE THAT WE'VE
PUT PARAMETERS ON THE MONEY. FOR
EXAMPLE WE WOULD REQUIRE THAT IT
BE ONLY USED FOR REIMBURSEMENT
FOR EQUIPMENT THAT HAS THAT
MEETS THE NEW AND CVS AS THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING SYSTEM
STANDARDS AND NOT TESTED TO THE
OLD SYSTEM THE OLD STANDARDS
WOULD WANT IT TO BE. THE NEW
GENERATION EQUIPMENT NOT LEGACY
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY'RE USING THE
MONEY FOR IT WILL NOT BE.
EASIER AND A CONVENIENT AND A
SAFER TO.
TRIED TO CHANGE. THE VOTING
SYSTEM AND NOW I'M ELECTION YOU
KNOW SO THAT THAT THEY CAN TEST
AND THE TRAIN UP PROPERLY RATHER
THAN JUST A RUSHED IN FEW MONTHS
HE HAD THE YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
REALLY UP TO THE DISCRETION OF
THE COUNTIES THAT YOU ABSOLUTELY
THAT WOULD BE.
IDEAL LIKE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT NEW EQUIPMENT SO
THEY'VE THEY'VE STARTED
SOCIALIZING AND LOOKING AT THE.
AT WHAT WOULD BE NEEDED AND WHAT
WOULD BE NECESSARY SO THERE MAY
BE SOME SOME COUNTIES THAT WOULD
ASSUMING WE GET CONTRACTS AND A
PLACE THAT THEY. WOULD BE READY
IN AND I NOVEMBER. BUT MOST IN
THE TO YOU ALL LIKE I AND
FORCING.
MANDATING TO.
.
A TWO IT THIS YEAR NO WE WOULD
NOT
SHIA.
WHAT ABOUT THE EIFFEL TOWER
MUSIC CANNOT COME UP WITH THE?
IDEA TO HALF.
I.
HE YOU KNOW IF THERE'S A IF THE
BILL PASSES AND IT'S A FIFTY
FIFTY MATCH WOULD BUT WORK
CLOSELY WITH COUNTIES TO SEE IF
THERE WAS SOME OF THE SOME WAY
THAT WE COULD ASSIST THEM ARE
GEORGE PRIDE.
OTHER RESOURCES AND WORK
CLOSELY WITH THEIR BOARDS TO SEE
IF THERE WAS THERE ANY OTHER
OPTIONS AWAY TO FIND FUNDING SO
IT WOULD WORK CLOSELY WITH THEM.
WHEN THE COUNTIES UNKNOWNS IS
COMING FOR A LONG TIME TO SELL.
I THINK THAT HOPE THAT'S COMING
FOR A LONG TIME.
THE GUILTY PUBLIC COMMON
ELEMENTS.
AT YOUR CHAIR OF UNTIL LEVINE I
AM REPPERT I'M FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SEE YEAH COUNTY. AND SO.
OKAY IT'S BROKEN AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE COUNTY CLERK'S
ASSOCIATION DAY COUNTY CLERKS.
ELECTION OFFICIAL AND SAY THE
WHOLE WORK IT'S.
AND THIS MONEY IS LIKE PLEASE
ARE VOTING SYSTEMS ARE OLD THEY
ARE DECREPIT THEY ARE CAUSING US
PROBLEMS AND.
YOU KNOW THE STANDARDS ARE HIGH
WE WANT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT US WITH OUR VOTING
SYSTEMS AND MONEY MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE A HUNDRED PERCENT.
WE FIGHT WITH OUR IN OUR COUNTY
THEM COUNTIES USE GENERAL FUND
MONEY TO GET A VOTING SYSTEM.
AND THIS IS NOT A SMALL PURCHASE
AND WHEN WE HAVE TO FIGHT
AGAINST OUR SHERIFFS AND ARE.
YOU KNOW. EVERYBODY ELSE IT'S SO
IT'S DIFFICULT.
MS EXAMPLE FOR SACRAMENTO COUNTY
WE'VE HAD OUR SYSTEM WE HAD OUR
SYSTEM SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR.
WHEN WE TRIED TO TEST IT WHEN WE
TESTED IT TOO FOR. LOGIC
INACCURACY FOR TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. THERE WAS A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT WE HAD AND IT TOOK
US QUITE AWHILE TO FIND ENOUGH
EQUIPMENT THAT WOULD PASS THE
TESTING SO WE COULD PUT IT OUT
THERE FOR TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN.
OUR CENTRAL COUNT MACHINE WAS SO
OLD THAT IT KIND OF SHAPE SIDE
OF A BALLOT OFF.
AND THE VENDOR SAID THE BEST
THING WE COULD DO IS PUT TAPE ON
IT.
SO YOU CAN SEE WHERE WE ARE IN
ONE IT SUSAN COMMENTED THAT WE
WERE LOOKING ON EBAY FOR PARTS
AND USING TAPE TO HOLD
EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
WE WANT THAT ACCURACY WE WANT
THESE NEW SYSTEMS SO THEY WILL
WORK AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY'S
ONLY ONE OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
THAT.
WE ARE ALL LOOKING FOR NEW
SYSTEMS.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE ON
THIS THANK YOU CLEAR STILL
THAT'S MONTHLY OF AMAZING STAFF
DOWN THERE. YEAH STARBASE THANK
YOU.
THE USER MUST RICHARD MISTER
TARA MEMBERS I'M JEANNE HURST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF THE
COUNTIES I HAVE. UP RIVERSIDE
SANTA CLARA AT SANTA CRUZ
INVENTOR ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS APPROPRIATION WE APPRECIATE
THE. WORK OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND.
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE TO
HELP US GET THERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I PROMISE YES SOME HAVE THEY SO
YOU OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE
SUPPORT THIS APPROPRIATION WE
AGREE THAT'S BADLY NEEDED THE
COUNTY LEVEL. AND WE ALSO JUST
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER.
.
CONSIDER WAYS THAT THE MONEY CAN
BE SPENT TO.
.
MAKE ELECTIONS MORE ACCESSIBLE
FOR FOR HISTORICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED VOTERS.
INCLUDING VOTERS WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES LINCOLN VOTERS IN
VOTERS OF COLOR IS A BIT OF A
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE WITH
SOME WAYS AND THAT YOU MIGHT DO
THAT AND WE HOPE YOU CONSIDER
THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHECK COOPER
AARON OF OUR IS FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY REGISTRAR'S OFFICE.
REPRESENTING THE LOGIN THAT
COUNTY REGISTRAR LA COUNTY AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CA CEO I
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OUR CORE
VOTING SYSTEM COMPONENTS DATE
BACK TO NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT
WHEN PUNCH CARD VOTING WAS.
ROLLED OUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS FUNDING ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA EFFORTS
IMPLANTS TO MODERNIZE ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE. BEEN STYMIED BY
SHRINKING AN INSUFFICIENT
PROPRIETARY MARKET AND AT TIMES
AN UNSTABLE AND INFLEXIBLE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE WHERE NOW
THE CUSP IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OF ROLLING OUT OUR VOTING
SOLUTIONS FOR ALL PEOPLE. AS
SUSAN'S MENTIONED.
THIS IS AN INITIATIVE THAT IS
ALIGNED WITH THE VOTERS CHOICE
ACT.
AND GROUNDED AND PUBLICLY OWNED
OPEN SOURCE DEVELOPED VOTING
SYSTEMS AND EQUIPMENT.
A FULLY REALIZING THE BENEFITS
OF SECURITY PROVISIONS OF THIS
MODEL.
IS
CONSISTENT AND NECESSARY BUT
ALSO REQUIRES A FUNDING
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORT THE
INITIAL INVESTMENT NECESSARY AND
OUTREACH EDUCATION AS WELL AS
IMPLEMENTATION SO AGAIN FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS FUNNY PROPOSAL.
PRETTY WELL THE RHETORIC REFLECT
EGGMAN VENOMOUS COMEY EURO.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MELINDA DUBROW FROM THE
REGISTRAR FROM SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY.
I'M HERE IT TO VOICE SUPPORT IN
OF THE FUNDING THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY.
JUST IT TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
OUR OUR SYSTEMS ARE.
SECURE IN ACCURATE.
BUT THE MACHINES ARE FALLING
APART.
WE HAVE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOTS THAT COME IN AND
THEY NEED TO BE HAND FED ONE BY
ONE INTO OUR SCANNING SYSTEM.
THE THE ROLLERS THAT FEED THE
PAPERS INTO THE SCANNERS ARE
SOLD WE CAN'T FIND.
REPLACEMENTS WE'VE HAD TO
SEARCH AROUND FOR THEM.
THE ROLLERS THAT WE HAVE OUR
GOOEY.
OF THE RUBBER IS DOING AND.
WE WANT VERY MUCH TO REPLACE
THE SYSTEMS
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT WE
WANT OF THE COUNTIES TO BE ABLE
TO USE THE FUNDS BASED ON OUR
OWN DETERMINATION OF OUR NEEDS.
SO THAT WHETHER WE ARE A.
VOTE CENTER COUNTY.
RIGHT OFF THE BAT OR WE WAIT.
AND.
IMPLEMENT VOTE CENTERS ON THE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT LATER WE WANT
TO HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO SPEND
THE FUNDS WHETHER IT'S A LEASE.
OF OR TWO BUT.
.
TO ADOPT TO THE EVOLVING
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE ALL SEE A
ELECTIONS.
YES THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
I WILL HAVE TO HOLD EXACT GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR COOPER AND
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS JESSE
SALINAS AND I AM THE YOLO COUNTY
ASSESSOR CLERK RECORDER. AND
REGISTER VOTERS
SAW THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
BE HERE TODAY AND TO SHARE. WHAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING SO IN YOLO
COUNTY WE HAVE A A WINDOWS TWO
THOUSAND CERTIFIED SYSTEM?
AND AS YOU KNOW MICROSOFT
DOESN'T SUPPORT THAT ANYMORE.
SO WE ARE EVER STILL HAD TO BE
ABLE TO USE THAT SYSTEM AND TO
GIVE YOU AN IDEA WE'VE HAD TO
REBUILD SOME COMPUTERS THAT HAVE
THE ABILITY STILL INTERFACE WITH
THAT SOFTWARE. AND LITERALLY
HAVE TO REBUILD THOSE COMPUTERS
FROM SCRATCH
BUT LET ME WALK YOU THROUGH KIND
OF A AN EVENING FOR US ON
ELECTION NIGHT TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF IT. AND WE START TO
PROCESS OUR BALLOTS IN THE
EVENING AS ALL THE BALLOTS ARE
COMING IN. AND THEN ABOUT TWO
HOURS AND WE HAVE TO STOP
EVERYTHING BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
FREEZE EVERYTHING AND THAT
APPOINTED TIME SO THAT WE CAN GO
AROUND. AND STOP THE MACHINES AT
OUR PROCESSING AT THAT ARE USING
SOME REALLY MODERN ART MEMORY
CARDS DIRECT. MEMORY KARCHER
FROM THE MID NINETEEN NINETIES
STANDARD.
SO THAT WAS BEFORE YOU S. BEES
SO GIVE ME AN IDEA WE LITERALLY
HAVE TO STOP IT HAS THAT THAT
PERSON HAS TO GO FROM SYSTEM TO
SYSTEM ONE BY ONE.
BUT HAS TO WALK OVER TO ANOTHER
SYSTEM PASSED TO PUT IT INTO THE
TALLY BOX THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A DIFFERENT COMPUTER WE THAT
HAVE TO THEN WALKED OVER TO
ANOTHER COMPUTER SO THAT WE CAN
NOW. SEND THAT REPORT OUT.
SO ALL THAT HAPPENS EVERY
ELECTION NIGHT MULTIPLE TIMES A
NIGHT AGAIN THE INEFFICIENCIES
THAT WERE ENCOUNTERING SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMITTEE UNDERSTAND WE REALLY
AREN'T LIVING ON BORROWED TIME.
AND IT'S JUST A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE THE SYSTEMS WE KNOW WE
CAN HAVE ARE ARE ITEMS THAT
WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF PARTS AND
SO FORTH SO WE REALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
GETTING IT DONE NOW. AND IT
GIVES US SO MUCH TO IMPROVE NOT
ONLY VOTER ACCESS BUT ARE
ESSENTIALLY THE PERFORMANCE OF
THE ELECTIONS AND SECURITY OF
THE PRINT OF THE ELECTIONS
MOVING FORWARD SO. WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BARBARA LEVY AND I AM
THE ASSESSOR CLERK RECORDER AND
REGISTERED VOTERS FOR MERCED
COUNTY.
MY STORY IS IS MUCH IS LIKE
YOU'VE HEARD FROM OUR OTHER
REGISTRARS WE HAVE AGING
EQUIPMENT OUR EQUIPMENT THE CORE
OF IT IS TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
I HAVE FOR US.
SOME OF OUR RECENT MORE RECENT
CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN FOR THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN
ELECTION.
I WAS DOWN TO ONE CENTRAL COUNT
UNIT.
I WHICH WOULD NOT SUFFICE I DID
WAS ABLE LEAST TWO MORE UNITS
FROM OUR VENDOR HOWEVER BY THE
END OF THAT ELECTION WE WERE
BACK DOWN TO ONE WORKING
TABULATOR. THAT TABULATOR
BECAUSE OF THAT NEED TO GET THAT
ELECTION COMPLETED RESULTS
DELIVERED AND THEN CERTIFIED WE
ARE RUNNING STAFF TWENTY HOURS A
DAY.
RUNNING SHIFTS TWENTY HOURS A
DAY TO GET THE VOLUME OF WORK
THROUGH THAT FIRMER SAID IT WAS
OUR HISTORIC HIGH REGISTRATION
AND OUR HISTORIC HIGH TURNOUT.
AND OUR EQUIPMENT BEING FROM TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WAS SIMPLY.
PURCHASED
AND THAT PREDICATED ON A
DIFFERENT VOLUME IN A DIFFERENT
VOTING CAPACITY
SO WE NEED WE NEED THE SUPPORT
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER
THE SERVICES ARE VOTERS. NEED
AND DEMAND AND HAVE A RIGHT TO
AND WE DO NEED THE FUNDING AND.
I KNOW MY COUNTY WOULD BE.
VERY AMENABLE TO THE MATCH
WE'VE DONE THAT BEFORE AND SOME
OF MY OTHER OFFICES I KNOW THAT
THAT WOULD BE. A WELCOME OUR
CRIED CRITERIA FOR THEM SO
PLEASE I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
FUNDING IF YOU THANK YOU ALLY
THE LINE FORMING WE'VE GOT A
VERY BUSY PACKAGE INTO AND. MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE JUST FIND OTHER
HEARINGS I DO. PLEASE HAVE YOUR
NAME YOUR IN SENIOR WITHIN THE
SUPPORTER NOT WOULD BE GREAT.
SURE STEVE CREWS ARE BEHALF FOR
THE SECOND A COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I KNOW YOU HEARD
FROM JILL EARLIER BUT CASEY WAS
ANY DOUBT SACRAMENTO'S FULLY
SUPPORTED.
THE.
I TREMBLING A PRISON THE CALVET
THE MONEY CAMPAIGN WE DO SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BUT I WANNA SPEAK A.
VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT OF WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU TALKED
ABOUT IN TERMS OF.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING NECESSARY
FOR DEVELOPMENT OF OPEN SOURCE
VOTING SYSTEMS.
MANY PEOPLE.
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM
WITH THE SECURITY OF CURRENT
PROPRIETARY SYSTEMS OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE TO.
REPLACE THE CURRENT BROKE
BROKEN DOWN ONCE. UP BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO HAVE AN
OPTION FOR OPEN SOURCE PAPER
BALLOT VOTING SYSTEMS OF THE
CALVET THE MONEY CAMPAIGN HAS
HAS MADE A PROPOSAL AND EVER
HAPPY TO. BE WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU IN CENTER
WIENER TO.
THEY HAVE PROPOSED A AN EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN MATCHING
FUNDS FOR COUNTIES TO DEVELOP.
AND THEN CERTIFY OPEN SOURCE
PAPER BALLOT VOTING SYSTEMS WE
BELIEVE THIS WOULD DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE SECURITY IN
TRANSPARENCY. OUR ELECTIONS.
AND A SAVE THE STATE A LOT OF
MONEY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JIM SOPER I AM
THE AUTHOR OF TONY DISCUSSED AT
WORK WHICH IS ABOUT ELECTIONS I
AM A SENIOR SOFTWARE ENGINEER.
THE PROPOSAL FOR OPEN SOURCE IS
NOT JUST ABOUT GETTING SERVICES
SCHOOL A BETTER AND CHEAPER
SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT SAVING
CALIFORNIA HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
IT'S ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
IT'S ABOUT KNOWING THAT VOTES IN
PENNSYLVANIA IN VIRGINIA AND
ALABAMA.
MATTER.
AND THAT THEY'RE CORRECT WE
CAN'T KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW SO I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR THIS SYSTEM THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE USED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN FOLKS NAME ORGANIZATION.
THE SUPPORTER OPPOSE THANK YOU.
CRAIG DUNKERLEY FROM SAN JOSE I
ALSO SERVE ON THE.
CITIZENS ADVISORY COMMISSION ON
ELECTIONS FOR SANTA CLARA COUNTY
A STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR MATCHING
FUNDS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
I'M GREGG PENNINGTON OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE STATE MATCHING FUNDS ONCE WE
LOSE OUR DEMOCRACY WE DON'T KNOW
WHEN OR IF WE CAN NEVER GET IT
BACK SO PLEASE PROTECT OUR
DEMOCRACY THANK YOU.
AND LISA HILLS FOR REDWOOD CITY
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THE CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN I'M JUST HERE TO
SUPPORT THE PUBLIC FUNDING FOR.
OPEN SOURCE ELECTIONS WE DON'T
WANT. ON ME ONE TRANSPARENCY IN
OUR ELECTIONS AND WE DON'T WANT
PRIVATE COMPANIES JUST
SELECT FEW TO BE COUNTING OUR
VOTES THING WHERE YOU.
I'M MARGARET MURRAY UP FROM
PINOLE.
AND I TO URGE YOU DO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU AND SENATOR
WIENERS REQUEST.
FOR MATCHING FUNDS TO CREATE
OPEN SOURCE PAPER BALLOT VOTING
SYSTEM THANK YOU.
HI I'M MARY BEVINS TO CEMETERY
ARMY ON TEACHER EXCEPTIONS CHO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AYE
PATAKI TO MY COLLEAGUES AND
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS ABOUT OPEN
SOURCE VOTING AND THEY ARE
STRONGLY STRONGLY FOR.
FOR IT AND I'M HOPING THAT ON
THE FUNDING WILL BECOME
AVAILABLE TO TO DEFEND OUR
DEMOCRACY BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
IT'S THAT IMPORTANT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I SUSAN PFEIFFER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M HERE TO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND STATE
SENATOR SCOTT WIENERS. REQUEST
FOR MATCHING FUNDS TO SUPPORT
OPEN SOURCE OF VOTING. MACHINES
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE LEARNED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THAT SECRET SOFTWARE IS MUCH
MORE VULNERABLE TO HACKING THAN
OPEN SOURCE AND THAT HAS BEEN
VIEWED BY MANY EYEBALLS THANK
YOU. ARE YOU.
MY NAME IS JUDY REYNOLDS I'VE
DAVIS CALIFORNIA WHICH IS FEEL
THE COUNTY I DEFINITELY SUPPORT
THE OPEN SOURCE FUNDING. AND
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THIS A FREE.
SYSTEM THAT CAN BE SHARED WITH
SAN FRANCISCO WHATEVER WITH EVER
COUNTY THAT DEVELOPS IT. IS FREE
FOR THE OTHER COUNTIES TO THEN
SHARE.
SO I SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S CHILDREN DAILY AND
I LIVE HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND I.
OF THAT SUPPORT THE OPEN SOURCE.
YOU.
MY NAME IS MARY BELL SHE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO I.
PORT OPEN.
OF A SORT OF FUNDING FOR OPRAH
OPENED.
SOURCE BOATING OF.
BALLOTS UP FOR MANY REASONS BUT
ALSO BECAUSE THEY CAN EXPAND AND
SERVE THE NEEDS OF. ALL OF US
WITHOUT REQUIRING AND.
GOING BACK TO THE OUTSIDE
VENDORS IT'S UP PUBLIC SYSTEM
VERSUS A PROPRIETARY. TERRY CON.
CONSISTENT
THANK YOU.
GOOD DAY ARE.
I AM IN ME CLAYTON SIME FROM
YOLO COUNTY AND LIVE IN DAVIS
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU AND SENATOR
WIENERS PROPOSAL FOR MATCHING
FUNDS FOR THE OPEN SOURCE PAPER
BALLOT VOTING.
THANK YOU.
I AM A LANDFILL WAVE I'M FROM
DAVIS.
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
THIS ON.
FUNDING FOR OPEN SOURCE.
I'M OPEN SOURCE SOFTWARE IS MORE
SECURE.
IT'S MORE IT'S TRANSPARENT AND
WILL HELP INCREASE THE TRUST
VOTERS HAVE IN OUR ELECTIONS
WHICH HAS BEEN REALLY ERODING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUT ANNA AND ME TO WORK TO
FOLKS.
YOU CAN DO THAT THAT'S RIGHT
GOODS BERSON FROM GILROY AND I
ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CHEERS.
OPEN SOURCE VOTING THANK YOU.
DAVID CARRY FROM BELMONT ME TO
FOR PAPER BASED OPEN SOURCE
VOTING SOCIETY BETTER.
MUCH APPRECIATED.
I'M DAN HOPPER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO RETIRED STATE WORKER
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT OPEN
SOURCE PAPER ABOUT A BALLOT
VOTING. FOR YOU.
HI AM PM JOHNSON SAN JOSE. I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS OPEN
SOURCE FUNDING.
BECAUSE IN THE LONG RUN IS
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN.
HELLO MY NAME IS LARRY BATHGATE
FROM MILL VALLEY CALIFORNIA THE
MARIN COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE OPEN SOURCE OF THE
VOTING SYSTEM WITH THE PAPER
BALLOTS. AND SOMEBODY ELSE WILL
MY THUNDER SO THANK YOU YOU.
MARY HAMLET FROM SACRAMENTO.
WITHOUT.
HONEST WE COUNTED ELECTIONS WE
HAVE NO DEMOCRACY SO I SUPPORT.
THE.
TRANSPARENT OPEN ELECTIONS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M JENNIFER HAY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO ON ME TOO.
I SUPPORT OPEN SYSTEMS PAPER
BALLOT. VOTING SYSTEMS THANK YOU
YOU.
ARE I AM ALAN PARKER FROM SANTA
CLARA. AND I MANAGE IT FOR MANY
SMALL AND MEDIUM BUSINESSES HAVE
MEASURE FOR LARGE BUSINESSES.
I CAN'T THINK OF A SAFER MORE
PRACTICAL AND MORE SECURE SYSTEM
LIBERAL OPEN LYRICS ALL PROGRAM
FOR VOTING. AS AFFECTED HIM A
BILL SO WHAT OTHER CITIES STATES
AND COUNTRIES.
THANK YOU.
ALEC CRASH FROM SAN FISCAL ON
ONE THE ADVISORY BOARD FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION VOTING
OFFICIALS WE'VE SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO YOU I WILL NOT READ
THAT.
ME TOO THANK YOU.
NANCY NOW FROM PALO ALTO IN
SUPPORT OF THE OPEN SOURCE
PROJECT.
BUT IF YOU.
KEVIN LOVE DAVIS CALIFORNIA ME
TO.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CITY WEBER OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR.
SIMPLY A PART OF CALIFORNIA. A
WE SUPPORTED PUBLICLY OWNED OPEN
SOURCE SYSTEM WE HOPE YOU
SUPPORTED AGAIN.
THANK YOU.
I'M SHELLY CAROL FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I SUPPORT OPEN SOURCE
PAPER BALLOTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SO FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU ALL
OUR SPEAKERS OF OF COMMON SPOKEN
TODAY SO YOU TRAVEL SEVERAL
HOURS TO COME HERE THUMBS WE
APPRECIATE THAT. ARABIC MAKE
INSULT IS WRITTEN DOWN.
WOULD JURISDICTIONS YOUR
FRIENDS WE HAVE AN IDEA SO
THAT'LL BE NOTED.
WITH RESEARCH COMING YOUR
COMMENTS
A PROVIDING FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
VOTING SYSTEMS SO THEY CAN CARRY
OUT ELECTIONS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF OUR STATE.
THE SUMMIT OF FUNDING IS
UNLIKELY TO BE ENOUGH.
WE A WHOLE THIS ITEM OPEN TO FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL FUNDING.
CONSIDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT SPECIFIES.
THE FUNDS MAY BE USED FOR AND
ALSO TALK ABOUT OR OPEN SOURCE
FROM FUNDING.
US WOULD HOLD US OPEN SO THANK
YOU.
WHEN OUR NEXT ITEM.
IT IS NOT IN NEVER TO SECRETARY
OF STATE.
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS CONNECT
PROJECT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN COOPER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I EMBEDDED BOGART AND HERE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF
STATE.
BUSINESS PROGRAMS DIVISION CHO
AND CO SPONSOR OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS CONNECT WHICH IS OUR IT
PROJECT THAT COME WE ARE SEEKING
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR TO
AUTOMATE. BUSINESS ENTITIES.
UNIFORM COMMERCIAL CODE AND
TRADEMARKS
WE'RE SEEKING EIGHTEEN POINT
FIVE ONE MILLION IN SPENDING
AUTHORITY.
FIFTEEN MILLION IN BUSINESS
FEES FUND AND THREE POINT FIVE
ONE MILLION IN BUSINESS
MONETIZATION FUND WHICH WAS IN.
CREATED TO MODERNIZE OUR.
CURRENT PAPER BASED SYSTEM.
WE HAVE.
PILOTED A.
.
FOR TRADE MARKS AN ONLINE
REGISTRATION IN A RECORD SEVEN
WEEKS.
THAT WE USED OUR DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES.
PROCUREMENT WITH THE VENDOR
HOSTED SOME
AFTER SERVICE.
I WHICH WAS A PRE APPROVED LIST
SO THAT CUT DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY
ON OUR PROCUREMENT.
WE ALSO.
USED A BAY AREA COMPANY THINK
SMART WITH THEIR SOFTWARE AS A
SERVICE CLOUD.
.
SOFTWARE.
AND A.
WE SEEK YOUR CONTINUED APPROVAL.
THANK YOU LL.
UP NEXT VOTER ELLIOTT NOTHING
TO.
LIGHTEN.
WHAT'S MOST SIGNIFICANT RISK
THE PROJECT BE COMPLETED. BY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
UC CONTINUED FUNDING IS PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST RISK.
WE WE HAVE AUTHORITY WE NEED
THE AUTHORITY TO SPEND THE MONEY
THAT WE COLLECT FROM BUSINESSES.
TO MOVE FORWARD WE HAVE CHANGED
WE HAVE US
SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT INTO
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY THAT IS IN
THE FINAL APPROVAL STAGE.
THAT MATCHES OUR FUNDING REQUEST
HERE.
.
WE HAVE REDUCED THE RISK FROM A
BIG BANG THEORY TO.
MODULE SMALLER I INCREMENTAL.
IMPLEMENTATION APPROACH SO WE
FEEL THAT THAT THAT'S GOING TO
HELP US AND IT'S GOING TO BRING
SUCCESSES.
ONLINE SERVICES TO CUSTOMERS
AND BUSINESSES MORE QUICKLY.
PLEASE DISCUSS WITH ELEMENTS OF
THE PROJECT HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED SO FAR AND WHAT IS
UP COMING.
SURE SO OUR MODULE APPROACH IS
TO DO BUSINESS ENTITY FORMS.
WHICH WILL BE A A SEPARATE
MODULE THAT WILL CONTINUE
THROUGH THE LIFE OF THE PROJECT.
WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED THE PILOT
FOR TRADE MARKS WHICH I SPOKE
ABOUT WHICH IS OUR SECOND
MODULE.
THE ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO ARE THE COULD CHANGE
FILINGS FOR THOSE.
AS WELL AS.
SEARCHES AND.
MIGRATE THE DATABASE OFF OF AN
ACCESS
DATABASE THAT IT CURRENTLY IS
AND.
AND THEN OUR UNIFORM COMMERCIAL
CODE WE ARE COMPLETELY REPLACING
THAT SYSTEM THAT'S ARE MY. THIRD
MODULE AND THEN OUR FINAL MODULE
WILL INCORPORATE THE BUSINESS
ENTITY FORMS. THAT HAVE BEEN.
PROVIDED ONLINE AND BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE BUSINESS
AND TO DECIDE WHICH IS CURRENTLY
ONTO MAINFRAME SYSTEMS.
A QUESTION COMMITTEE.
INCOMES RUMORS OF PUBLIC.
OKAY NO COMMENT.
SELECT HOLD SADDAM OPEN.
WANT TO OUR NEXT ITEM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
JUST ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
VETERANS HOME.
I'M TRYING TO FROM THE VETERANS
AFFAIRS.
VINCENT OF CALIFORNIA YOU DON'T
BUILD SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR MY
NAME IS COBY PETERSON DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR THE VETERANS ON
SOME OF.
CALIFORNIA I'VE.
NUMBER OF FOLKS WITH ME TODAY
THE COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME ST GERARD
ASSISTANT DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT THAT'S FAIRS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THOMAS MARMOSET
STEP A SECRETARY FOR VETERANS.
SO COME HALF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
REPRESENTS A PROPOSAL FOR A
BRAND NEW TWO HUNDRED FORTY.
BED SNIFF BUILDING AT THE ON
BILL VETERANS HOME.
OF THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL AYE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
REFLECTS FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PRELIMINARY PLANS.
AND THE CUSTOMARY DESIGN BID
BILL DELIVERY SYSTEM.
SINCE THAT TIME WE HAVE DONE AN
EVALUATION OF THE PROPERTY.
SOME ENVIRONMENTAL.
STUDIES.
SOME VALUE.
ANALYSIS AND HAVE COME BACK
WITH A PROPOSAL THAT REFLECTS A
NEW.
DELIVERY SYSTEM DESIGNED BUILT.
THAT THE DESIGN BUILD.
PROPOSAL REFLECTS THE REQUEST
OF SEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA.
THE DESIGN BUILD A PROPOSAL
REFLECTS.
WHAT WE THINK?
IS.
ADDED VALUE FOR THE STATE.
AND OVERALL IT IS A REDUCTION IN
TWENTY THREE POINT.
IT'S MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THEY.
REDUCTION IN SCHEDULE OF SIX TO
POTENTIALLY TWELVE MONTHS TIME.
LL.
JACKIE REST OF AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA.
WE DO RAISE SOME INITIAL
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL BUT
LARGELY JUST TAKING A STEP BACK.
.
THE THE RATIONALE BEHIND THE
PROPOSAL AS WE UNDERSTAND FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION IS THAT THERE
ARE SOME CHALLENGES WITH THE
CURRENT FACILITIES AND YAWNED
BILL. IN.
DUE TO THEIR AGE OR THEIR
DESIGN THAT MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
PROVIDE RESIDENTS WITH.
HIGH LEVELS OF CARE AND THEN
ALSO JUST THE COORDINATION OF
THEIR EVERYDAY ACTIVITIES IS
WHILE.
AND DO WE AGREE THAT THIS DOES
PRESENT AN ISSUE I THINK ARC
MAIN CONCERNS REVOLVE AROUND THE
PROCESS IN WHICH THIS IS
HAPPENING. CURRENTLY.
THERE IS THE DEPARTMENT IS
WORKING ON A LEGISLATIVELY
REQUESTED MASTER PLAN THAT
MAINLY IS HOPING TO LOOK AT NOT
ONLY WHAT CURRENT NEEDS ARE BUT
THEN ALSO FUTURE DEMANDS WITHIN
THE VETERANS HOMES. SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN USE THAT AS A
TOOL TO BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW TO
PRIORITIZE FUTURE CHANGES WITHIN
THE ENTIRE VETERAN HOME SYSTEM
MEAN ACROSS ALL EIGHT OF THE
VETERANS HOMES. ON AND THEN
WATER THE ASSOCIATED TRADE OFFS
OF ANY CHANGES MADE TO THE
VETERAN HOME SYSTEM AS YOUR
PRIORITIZING THOSE PROJECTS.
BE IT NEAR TERM OR THE LONG TERM
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT.
.
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IN
GENERAL.
IT A LACK OF A MASTER PLAN
REALLY.
RAISES SOME INITIAL QUESTIONS
THAT JUST AREN'T ANSWERED QUITE
YET.
AS OUTLINED IN YOUR GENDER
THOSE QUESTIONS REALLY REVOLVED
AROUND ONE. HOUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION PROJECTING THAT
THE PROPOSED CAPACITY OF THESE
NEW FACILITIES WHICH MAINLY
WOULD JUST REPLACE.
THE CURRENT FACILITY OF SPENT
YOUNG FELLA WOULDN'T NECESSARILY
EXPAND CAPACITY ON IS THE BEST
SIZE TO NOT ONLY MEET CURRENT
DEMAND BUT ALSO FUTURE DEMAND.
ALSO ARE THERE OTHER PLANS I'M
IN ADDITION TO THIS ONE TO
EXPAND CAPACITY WITHIN THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY AND
WITHIN THE SKILLED NURSING OR
MEMORY CARE SERVICES WHICH
CURRENTLY. IS ON ONE OF THE
HIGHER UNMET NEEDS WITHIN THE
CALM CALVET SYSTEM AND ANOTHER
QUESTION TO JUST LOOKING FORWARD
THERE SEEMS TO BE TO AT TIMES
COMPETING. PRIORITIES AT PLAY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE CALVET
SYSTEM ONE IS YOU WANT TO
MAINTAIN CAPACITY IN ORDER TO
MEET CURRENT NEEDS. BUT ANOTHER
AND YOU ALSO WANT TO EXPAND
CAPACITY IN LIGHT OF ANY FUTURE
DEMAND OR UNMET NEED THAT WE
CURRENTLY SEE IN IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS PROPOSAL IS ON THE SIDE OF
MAINTAINING CAPACITY.
BUT LACK OF MASTER PLAN IT'S
REALLY UNCLEAR WHAT ARE THE
ASSOCIATED TRADE OFFS OF
MAINTAINING CAPACITY AS OPPOSED
TO EXPANDING CAPACITY IN THE
NEAR TERM. AND IS THERE A LONG
TERM THAN PLANNED TO GET UP THAT
EXPANDED CAPACITY ISSUE AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DELAY THE CHECK
THE PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE
ACCOUNT THAT VETERAN HOMES. FOR
THE END WITHIN THE VETERAN HOME
SYSTEM.
PENDING THE COMPLETION OF THE
MASTER PLAN WHICH IS SCHEDULED
TO BE COMPLETED JULY TWENTY
NINETEEN AND WE ALSO RAISE OTHER
QUESTIONS.
THAT OTHER ISSUES AROUND TO
THIS POTENTIALLY IS ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
INTO CLARIFY THE INTENT OF THE
MASTER PLAN AND PERHAPS.
PROVIDE FURTHER GUIDANCE OF THE
OUTCOMES OF THE MASTER PLAN IN.
YOUR ATTENDED DOES LAY OUT IN
THE STAFF COMMENT SECTION ONE
LOOKING AT THE MODEL OF CARE
WITHIN THE CALVET AND SYSTEM IF
ENOUGH THAT SOMETHING OF
INTEREST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPLORE.
IN THIS LONG TERM MASTER PLAN
CONCEPT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT.
YOU COULD ADD AS AN OBJECTIVE
IN THE MASTER PLAN AND SCOPE
PROPERLY BUT AGAIN WE ALSO
RAISED THE ISSUE OF ANY
ADDITIONAL OUTCOMES ARE THINGS
THAT ARE TACKED ON TO THE MASTER
PLAN TO ALSO LOOK AT THE
RESOURCES ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
WELL I THINK YOU'RE VERY
THOROUGH IN YOUR COMMENTS IN
THOSE ACTUALLY DOVETAIL INTO MY
QUESTIONS ON.
THE MASTER PLAN IS FIFTEEN
MONTHS WAY.
IT WAS LIVE NEXT YEAR SO.
CAN YOU ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS
CERTAINLY SO ON.
THE THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU IS FROM A TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN MASTER PLAN
THAT WE DID SPECIFICALLY.
SPECIFICALLY AT THE APPLE
VETERANS HOME.
THE NUMBERS.
THAT ARE IN THE PROPOSAL
REFLECT THE CURRENT.
SNIFF.
BED COUNT A LITTLE BIT OF THE
WAITING LIST.
AND IT ALSO REFLECTS THE
ADEQUATE SIZE THAT THE PROPERTY
CAN CAN HANDLE.
THE IF YOU ASK IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR WHAT WOULD AN ADEQUATE
SIZE OF A SNIFF BUILDING IS TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY BEDS IS
GETTING TOWARDS THE MAXIMUM WE
HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH OUR WITH
OUR CURRENT NEW HOMES. AND WE'RE
FINDING THAT.
TWO HUNDRED TO THREE HUNDRED IS
IS ABOUT THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT SO
OUR OUR.
THAT THE NUMBER THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING REFLECTS.
SOME INTERNAL ANALYSIS THAT
WE'VE DONE IT REFLECTS THE
ANALYSIS DONE A TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AND IT DOES REPLACE THE
EXISTING SNIFFED BUILDING. THE
EXISTING STAFF BUILDING IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY POOR.
CONDITION AT ANY GIVEN TIME ANY
OF OUR CONTROL AGENCIES PUBLIC
HEALTH CMS YOU STV A CAN GOING
INSIDE THE US FOR ANY NUMBER OF
THINGS YET THEY UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION THEY DON'T GO SO FAR
AS TO SAY THIS IS UNFIT. FOR
LIVING BUT THEY DO CALL US OUT
SO AT ANY GIVEN TIME WERE
THROWING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY HALF
A MILLION DOLLARS AT ANY.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF OF REPAIRS
AND SO FORTH.
WE FEEL THAT REGARDLESS OF THE
ANALYSIS THAT'S GOING TO BE
DONE.
THE THE END RESULT WILL BE A
NEED FOR A NEW STAFF BUILDING AT
THE OUTFIELD VETERANS HOME. ON
THAT IF YOU WERE TO DELAY THIS
THE THE FACT THAT WE ARE HERE
TODAY IS.
EVER SINCE I BEGAN IT CAL THAT
WHICH IS IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
WE'VE BEEN PUSHING FORWARD WITH
A REQUEST FOR A NEW SNIFFED
BUILDING.
THERE IS MOMENTUM AT STAKE.
GETTING STAKEHOLDERS TO.
TO BUY OFF ON THE IDEA GETTING
THE U. S. DEVIATE TOO ACCEPTED
GRANT AND ACCEPT THAT GRANT LAST
WEEK WE JUST UPDATED OUR PRE
APPLICATION WITH U. S. DBA. TO
STAY WITHIN THEIR BUDGET CYCLE
SO IT'S NOT JUST.
ALLOWING FOR THIS EXERCISE TO
OCCUR AND PUTTING THAT THEN BACK
IN PLACE AFTER FIFTEEN MONTHS
WE'RE GOING TO DELAY IT MUCH
LONGER THAN THAT BECAUSE OF THE
THE MOMENTUM PROCESS THAT HAS TO
OCCUR.
SO SELECT CREEK THE ARGUMENT IS
THE SIZE THE FACILITY WILL NOT
CHANGE RUN THAT TO LEARN WITH A
TUNER FORTY BED MAXIMUM. THAT
DOES SO THAT'S THE PROPOSAL THAT
WERE WERE MAKING WE FEEL BASED
ON SOME OF THE EVALUATIONS THAT
WE'VE DONE ENVIRONMENTALLY AND
AND SO FORTH THAT THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER THEY'LL HAVE
TO BE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
EVALUATION DONE ON THE ENTIRE
PROPERTY TO. TO ADDRESS THIS SO
EVEN THAT WILL WILL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE SIGNS. ON THE
STATE HA HISTORIC PRESERVATION
OFFICE WILL WILL COMMENT ON THE
APPROPRIATESIZE IT HAS TO MATCH
THE EXISTING STRUCTURE BECAUSE
THE FACILITIES SO ALL. THERE ARE
SO MANY OTHER THINGS THAT ARE IN
PLAY OTHER JUST AN ANALYSIS THAT
COMES BACK AND SAYS.
THIS IS WHAT'S NECESSARY AT THIS
PARTICULAR TIME ARE SYSTEM WIDE.
OTHER LARGER SNIFF AUTHORITIES
IN THE COUNTRY.
OR DOES IT SO SO THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF ALL THE SENATE
FACILITIES CROSS COUNTRY TO
HONOR BETTER LESS
BUT THERE'S A FIVE PERCENT THAT
ARE A LITTLE SO. WE ARE THE
LARGEST
WE ARE NOW THAT THE LARGEST I
MEAN WHEN YOU LOOK IN IN
COMPARISON AND SCOPE OF SIZE.
IS IT IS A REALLY APPLES APPLES
COMPARISON THERE WAS AB ITS OR
IT IF IT'S NOT A SELL OT IS THE
WHAT WE WANNA DO IS WHEN
ADDRESSED THAT THE NEED THE
AUDIENCE THE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE IN THE NEXT FIVE TEN TWENTY
YEARS WE WANT TO BUILD. A
FACILITY THAT'S TOO LARGE THAT
DOESN'T HAVE THE AUDIENCE ON THE
OTHER HAND.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WITH ANY
OF. ANY NEW CONSTRUCTION OR ANY
SITE LOCATION IS IS GOING TO BE
THE IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITY SO
IF YOU PUT A FIVE HUNDRED BED
FACILITY IN THE NAPA COUNTY
BURDEN THE ALPHA HOME THAT'S.
THAT'S GONNA OVERWHELM DID THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE ABILITY TO%
TAKE CARE OF THAT AND THAT'S WHY
WHEN DAVE SAID THAT THEY'VE PUT
A LOT OF THOUGHT AND AND ENERGY
INTO.
WHAT WHAT WILL WHAT WILL WORK
THERE? IT SO HAPPENS TO BE
FAIRLY CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE
HAVE NOW.
THE THE OTHER THING THAT I WOULD
ADD IS THAT THE.
.
THE REQUEST FOR PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA.
SATISFIES A STANDARD.
SO THAT THE STANDARD BY WHICH
THE THE FACILITY WILL BE BUILT.
THE NUMBER IS IRRELEVANT.
THE NUMBER CAN ALWAYS BE
ADJUSTED SO WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA BE ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE IN PARALLEL WITH THE
MASTER PLAN.
CERTAINLY RETARDED REP OF THE
NUMBER CAN BE ADJUSTED SO
THERE'S. THERE'S ENOUGH
SPACE TO TO BUILD OUTER. REFER
ADDITIONS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
WHAT MS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS IS
THAT THE PERFORMANCE CRITERIA
AND THE NUMBER OF OF THE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY BED.
PROPOSAL COULD BE ADJUSTED TO
BE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE MASTER
PLAN NEED AT THE END OF THAT
FIFTEEN MONTH PERIOD. ALL I'M
SUGGESTING IS THAT WE SEE THAT
AS POTENTIALLY A COMPROMISE THAT
ALLOWS BOTH TO CONTINUE IN
PARALLEL WE RESPECT THE FACT
THAT THE THE.
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE A MASTER
PLAN DONE ON A SYSTEM WIDE BASIS
WE DON'T.
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT BUT WE
SEE THAT BOTH PROPOSALS CAN GO
FORWARD IN PARALLEL NOT LINEAR
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE PUT IN TO A
LINEAR FASHION. WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE IS A MUCH LONGER
DELAY THAN SIMPLY JUST FIFTEEN
MONTHS FOR AN ANALYSIS TO BE
DONE?
OKAY A FINANCE.
YES DAHLE LOOKING BUILT PARTNER
FINANCE SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING
REALLY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON THIS PROPOSAL FOR
SOMETIME NOW. AND WE FEEL
STRONGLY THAT SUPPORT TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH IT AT THIS TIME AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
IT'S THE TO
THE DEPARTMENT ALREADY STATED.
HALDERMAN HOSPITAL HAS UP SOME
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT OPERATIONAL
AND FUNCTIONAL FOUND
DEFICIENCIES NOT TO MENTION A
FIRE LIKE SAFETY DEFICIENCIES.
AND WHAT WE AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THE MASTER PLAN MIGHT DELIVER.
SOME FINDINGS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION A ONE ACT ON IT
SOME SOME LATER DATE.
WE FEEL THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT
IT IT CONSIDERS THE CONDITION OF
THE HALDERMAN FACILITY IT IT IS
GOING TO COME TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION WHICH IS THAT THAT.
FACILITY NEEDS TO BE REPLACED
THE SAME CONCLUSION AS THE
BUTTON. NAM DON'T GO MASTER PLAN
FOR TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THOUGH THAT.
SO THIS THIS.
.
STUDY WON'T BE DONE UNTIL JULY
SO THE NEXT IF IF THIS IS DONE
IN A LINEAR FASHION HAS OF MR
DRIVE WAS SAYING.
THEN WE COULDN'T CONSIDER THIS
AGAIN UNTIL THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET SO THAT PUTS IT OUT
TWO YEARS IN THAT ALSO.
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASES THE
PROJECT COST ARMING ESCALATION
ALONE IT WOULD BE EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY.
AND ABOUT YOU KNOW WHO KNOWS
WHAT OTHER FACTORS MIGHT BE
AFFECTING AT THAT TIME SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE'S AGREEMENT
THAT THE.
.
YOU KNOW THE FACILITY NEEDS TO
BE REPLACED IN THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PROJECT MOVE FORWARD
WITH IT SPEED BE PRUDENT TO DO
SO NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THE COMEDIAN AND STAFFERS SAID
HERE ABOUT THE LOSS OF YOUR
EMPLOYEES EARLIER THIS YEAR. AT
THE ALPHA VETERANS HOME.
UNDERSTAND CHP IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN PROVIDING ASSESSMENT OF THE
SECURITY ON CAMPUS.
HE DISCUSS WHAT YOU'VE DONE TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES RAISED NOT
ASSESSMENT IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
SO I'M WE ARE NOT PREPARED TO TO
RESPOND TO TWO QUESTIONS OF
SECURITY.
BASED ON THE ON GOING
INVESTIGATION AT THIS TIME SO MY
APOLOGIES FOR THAT.
AT A FURTHER DATE WE CAN
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION SURE
AND IT WITH THIS COMMITTEE DOES
HAVE AN INTEREST IN HEARING
WHAT.
WAS DONE NO SLOW AFTER THAT THE
TWO THOUSAND CENSUS MINUTES
EIGHT YEARS LATER SO THERE'S A
STRONG INTEREST. FOR HIM TO SEE
WHAT IS DONE AND YOU KNOW
WHETHER ACTIONS BEING TAKEN TO.
TO BE PARTICULARLY THEIR SO AT
SOME POINT.
WITH UNDERSERVED BACK AND DID IT
DO PRESENTATION OF THE
COMMITTEE.
INTEREST SO MANY QUESTIONS IN
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THIS
ISSUE.
COUPLES PUBLIC COMMENT.
ENSURE THE STATE'S VETERANS
HOMES HAVE POLISH AUTHORITIES TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS IS AGES
CRITICAL FOR LONGTIME THE
FACILITIES THAT HELP FILL A BIT
OUT OF DATE. ACOSTA TO MAINTAIN
THIS PROPOSAL ATTEMPTS TO
CORRECT THAT HOWEVER.
PROPOSAL IS COMING OUT IN
ADVANCE OF THE SYSTEM WIDE
MASTER PLAN THAT LEGISLATURE
DIRECTED CALVET TO DEVELOP TO
ADDRESS THE FUTURE NEEDS OF THE
VETERANS.
OUR COUNTRY IS MOVING DIRECTION
PROVIDING COMMUNITY BASED CARE
AND SO THE PROVIDING CARE
INSTITUTIONS THEREFORE IT WAS
REASONABLE TO EXPECT THE MASTER
PLAN MIGHT TAKE THE NEED. TO
PLACE NOW BILL IS OPPORTUNITY TO
BEGIN DEVELOPING A COMMUNITY
BASED CARE APPROACH.
A COMMUNITY BASED APPROACH WILL
LIKELY DEVELOP A GREATER NUMBER
OF SMALLER SINGLE STORY
FACILITIES THAT ALLOW VETERANS
TO REMAIN PHYSICALLY CLOSER TO
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITY. HOWEVER
THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO PROVE
THIS PROPOSAL IT WOULD MAINTAIN
THE STATUS QUO THE INSTITUTIONAL
CARE AND DO NOTHING TO HELP THE
VETERANS AGE. IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES
WE'RE HOLDING OPEN THE SIDE OF
TO RALPH TYPE FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION.
TO CONSIDER IF ADDITIONAL STEPS
NEED TO BE TAKEN TO BETTER
ENSURE THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
MASTER PLAN IS CONSISTENT WITH
OUR VETERANS NEEDS IN THE
FUTURE.
THREE WHOLE THIS ITEM OPEN HOPE
FOR YOU A.
TAKE OUR COMMENTS TO
CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHEN OUR NEXT AUTUMN.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
AND REPORTING LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATURE ON THE VETERANS ON
TO CALIFORNIA. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE.
MOMENT.
HIGH ON GOOD AFTERNOON MY MY
NAME IS BEST MISSION SCHEME AND
CHIEF OF RESEARCH AND PROGRAM
REVIEW FOR THE VETERANS HOMES
DIVISION. ON MY WON'T.
GOING TO TO TOO MUCH DETAIL
BECAUSE YOU HAVE IT RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU AND I THINK IT'S
SOME IT'S PRETTY. CLEAR AND
CONCISE AND EASY TO UNDERSTAND
WE ARM.
WE ARE.
REQUESTING THE FUNDING FOR.
POSITION ONE.
OTHER THAN CAPITAL ASSETS UNIT
RELATED TO.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE TRACKING
IT CETERA AND.
ONE WITHIN ARE COUNTING OF THE
UNIT.
TO ADDRESS THE COST
CALCULATIONS THAT COMPONENT OF
IT I'M I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS UNLESS YOU LIKE TO
HEAR ADDITIONAL EVER FEEL. THAT
YOU FAILURE.
FINANCE.
THE QUESTION THE COMMITTEE.
ANYONE WISHES NICHOLAS ON
PUBLIC.
OKAY THERE NO CONCERNS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ON
THIS ITEM STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
TO PROVE THE PROPOSAL AND UP
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ADD TO THE ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
YOU COME IN THE CALVET PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON ALL THE LEASES
AND OTHER THIRD PARTY USES OF
STATE PROPERTY AND CAL THAT'S A
VETERANS HOMES.
I SHOULD LEASES THE STATE
INTEREST ENTERS INTO
APPROPRIATE.
WILL HELP FORM RIGHT NOW
THROUGH THE WHOLE THIS ITEM
OPEN.
EVEN IF YOU.
PUT IT ON YOUR NEXT ITEMS GIVES
ME PART.
PARDEE CHAIR SORRY YOUR CHILD
PARTNER FINANCE WE JUST WANTED
TO KNOW THAT.
THE PER OF THE TRAILER BILL IS
NOT A PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. AND.
Y. WE HAVEN'T
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NATALIE DANIEL I'M DEAD DEBBIE
DIRECTOR OF ADMINISTRATION AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF STAFF HERE
THAT CAN HELP ASSIST WITH ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
DCA HAS TO PROPOSALS IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY.
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SP ONE SEVENTY THREE.
THE FIRST IS A FALL BCP WHICH IS
ACTUALLY REDIRECTS ELEVEN
POSITIONS AND THEIR ASSOCIATED
COSTS.
FROM THE DCA TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF REAL ESTATE WHICH WOULD
EFFECTIVE JULY ONE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THIS PROPOSAL ALSO ADD
SEVEN ADDITIONAL STAFF TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE AND
ALLOWS FOR THEM TO CONTRACT WITH
DC A. FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES BY MEANS OF AN
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT.
AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR UP TO
TWO MILLION DOLLARS THE SECOND
PROPOSAL IS A SPRING FINANCE
LETTER THAT PROPOSES ADDITIONAL.
AND INCREMENTAL REACH YOUR.
I'M SORRY REDUCTIONS TO DCA
CENTRAL AYE STAFF FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AN ON GOING.
THE FINANCE WATER REDUCTIONS ARE
PROPOSED IN ADDITION TO THE FALL
BCP AND SHE WANTED TO LEAVE THE
FINANCE WATER WILL REDUCE DCA
CENTRALIZED SERVICES BY FIFTEEN
POSITIONS.
AND.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE BALL B.
CP THAT WOULD TOTAL TWENTY SIX
POSITIONS AND APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
EARLIER.
PULLING CURSING AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
TEST WE HAVE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THESE TWO
PROPOSALS. UP FIRST WITH REGARD
TO THE JANUARY PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND THAT WILL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO BEGIN CAPTURING
DATA ON PAST CLIENT USAGE AND
WORKLOAD.
PARTICULARLY FOR ITS MAIN
SERVICE SEGMENTS OF THOSE ARE
THINGS LIKE OF LEGAL SERVICES IN
HR SERVICES.
REFER THEM. I RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT'S
REPORT THIS INFORMATION.
I'M SO THE MAIN RATIONALE BEHIND
THIS RECOMMENDATION. I IS THAT
IT DOES APPEAR THAT THE BUREAU
OF REAL ESTATE WITH LIKELY
OVERPAYING FOR DCA SERVICES. A
MINUTE THEN CLEAR TO US HOW
WIDESPREAD THE ISSUE IS WHETHER
IT WAS. MOSTLY AT REAL ESTATE OR
WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING THAT
AFFECTED MORE BOARDS AND
BUREAUS.
I'M SO IT'S JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THE ISSUE ON THE
ISSUE OF CROSS SUBSIDIZATION AND
CONCERNS ABOUT PERRETTA HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN QUITE LONG
STANDING OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS
DURING THE SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS
THAT. OF THE LEGISLATURE
CONDUCTS EVERY YEAR ON THEIR OF
BEEN CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT THIS
ISSUE I'M SO IT'S NOT A NEW
ISSUE.
.
CERTAINLY.
I'M A PRETTY THIS REALLY ARISES
BECAUSE THEY THE DEPARTMENT I'M
ASSESSES ITS CHARGES ON A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT. BUT RIGHT
DEFERRED PURCHASE INCLUDING
POSITION BASED.
APPROACHES IT'S NOT CLEAR IF A
POSITION ALLOCATION THAT THOSE
ARE THE POSITIONS AT THE BOARDS
AND HEROES IF THAT'S REALLY
REFLECTIVE OF THE WORKLOAD THAT
THEY REQUIRE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT.
SECTION NOTABLY ARE THE LEVEL
OF PRO RATA THAT WAS BEING A
FAST ON THE BUREAU OF REAL
ESTATE WAS ONE OF THE MAIN
RATIONALES BEHIND THIS
LEGISLATION TO MOVE THEM OUT OF
THE DEPARTMENT.
AND.
IN FACT THAT RELATIVELY HIGH
LEVEL OF PER RATHER THAT THEY
WERE PAYING.
IS REFLECTED AS HE SAID IN THE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU SEE.
SPECIFICALLY IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN OTHER BUREAU WAS PAYING
ABOUT FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN PRO RATA HOWEVER I
HAD THEM THAT PROPOSAL
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANTLY
SMALLER REDUCTION IN THEIR
BUDGET EVEN ACCOUNTING FOR APRIL
LETTER.
WE WOULD NOTICIAS PROVIDED SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IN
RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNS THAT
WE'VE RAISED INCLUDING I THINK I
AM A VERY RECENTLY UPDATED.
DOCUMENT.
BUT WE STILL THINK.
THAT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW WIDESPREAD
THIS CROSS SUBSIDIZATION IS
WHETHER IT'S JUST RELATED TO TO
THE BUREAU OF REAL ESTATE OR
WHETHER THIS IS REALLY I'M I'M
MORE WIDESPREAD ISSUE. UP AND
SAID WE THINK SOME OF THOSE.
STILL DEFINITELY NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED OUR RECOMMENDATION
WOULD HELP ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
OTHER REPORTS WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO BETTER ASSESS
THIS LEVEL OF CROSS OF CITIES
SUBSIDIZATION AND DETERMINE
WHETHER. ANY OTHER METHODOLOGIES
USED FOR ALLOCATING COSTS.
AND THE SECOND WITH REGARD TO
THE APRIL FIRST LETTER. WE
RECOMMEND THAT DCA THAT BE AT
LEGISLATURE PREVIEW CA'S
REQUESTED REDUCTIONS FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
BUT NOT APPROVE THAT REQUESTED
IT REDUCTIONS FOR THE OUT YEARS
AT THIS POINT.
INSTEAD HOW THE DEPARTMENT COME
BACK IN REQUEST THOSE AT A
FUTURE DATE.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
INDICATE THAT IT BELIEVES THAT
IT CAN MAKE THESE REDUCTIONS
WITHOUT AFFECTING THE SERVICE
LEVELS PROVIDED TO THE OTHER
BOARDS AND BUREAUS. HOWEVER IT'S
NOT CLEAR TO US THAT THIS IS
CASE AND THIS IS BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS YET TO IDENTIFY
THE SPECIFIC POSITIONS THAT WILL
BE REDUCED.
AND THEREFORE DOESN'T HAVE A
GOOD SENSE OF.
SPECIFIC WAYS THAT IT'S GOING TO
CHANGE ITS OPERATIONS WHETHER
IT'S GONNA HOW IT CAN ABSORB THE
WORKLOAD THOSE FOLKS WERE DOING
OR REDISTRIBUTED ARE REALLY WHAT
THE EFFECTS ARE GOING TO BE.
I'M SO WE THINK BY TAKING THIS
APPROACH IN JUST APPROVING THE
FIRST YEAR IT WILL ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO REVISIT THOSE.
THAT'S THESE REDUCTIONS IN A
FEW KEY IT NEXT YEAR BASICALLY
HOW THE DEPARTMENT COME BACK
THEY CAN REPORT ON THE EFFECTS
OF THESE REDUCTIONS ON WHICH
POSITIONS THE ELIMINATED WITH
THE EFFECTS WORK AS WELL AS
WHICH POSITIONS THEY'RE
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE IN FUTURE
YEARS. I MEAN WE ALSO THINK THAT
THE WORKLOAD INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT THEY
COLLECT COULD BE VERY VALUABLE
IN FUTURE YEARS FOR INFORMING.
LEGISLATIVE DECISION MAKING
ABOUT THE APPROPRIATE STAFFING
LEVELS FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
LIZZY PARENTS APARTMENT FINANCE.
.
JUST WANT TO.
PROVIDE A COUPLE OF NOTES.
IN RESPONSE TO THE ELLIOTTS
CONCERNS WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
LONGSTANDING CONCERNS REGARDING
DC'S PRO RATA METHODOLOGY.
HOWEVER THE ADMINISTRATION DOES
SUPPORT THE CURRENT STRUCTURE
BECAUSE WE FEEL LIKE IT'S AN
EQUITABLE WAY TO DISTRIBUTE
ACOSTA BOARDS AND BUREAUS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES.
WE FEEL THAT THIS PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCESS TO ALL THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WITHOUT
pWITHOUT.
INCREASING COSTS TO DEPARTMENTS.
I DO WANT TO NOTE A COUPLE OF
POINTS THAT.
DC IS CENTRALIZED SERVICES.
MOST OF THEM ARE TRACKED.
AND ACCOUNTED FOR.
ON AN BONTA USE BASIS THE
REMAINING SERVICES ARE CHARGED.
AS PRO RATA BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF POSITIONS BECAUSE THOSE.
POLICY SERVICES CAN'T ALWAYS BE
ATTRIBUTED TOOK FROM ONE BORDER
BUREAU.
HOWEVER.
WE NOTE THAT DCA DOES PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY AND MEETS WITH ALL
OF THE BOARDS BUREAUS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS TALKS ABOUT THOSE
PRO RATA CHARGES AND WHAT THOSE
SERVICES WILL INCLUDE I'M ON A
YEAR TO YEAR BASIS.
ALSO A JUST A COUPLE OF POINTS
AND CONCERNS THAT DEPARTMENT
FINANCE HIGHS ABOUT TRACKING
THE.
USAGE IS.
BUDGET PLANNING WOULD BE REALLY
UNPREDICTABLE IF WE MOVED TO
THIS TYPE OF SYSTEM OF ALL BASED
ON.
TRACKING IN USAGE.
PRO RATA CHARGES COULD SPIKE IN
ANY GIVEN YEAR AND ON A AN
OPERATIONAL BASIS THAT PROVIDES
A LOT OF.
UNCERTAINTY FOR BOARDS AND
HEROES AND PRETTY CA I WAS.
ONE BUDGET COULD GO UP BECAUSE
THEY'RE NEAT IN NEED OF MORE
SERVICES AND.
DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDS TO
COVER THOSE SERVICES IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE DIET A DCA
DOESN'T CURRENTLY HAVE A SYSTEM
TO SUPPORT IT.
THE TRACKING OF THEIR WORKLOAD
AT THIS POINT TIME AND SO IT
WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF POSSIBLY.
BESOS PROGRAM THAT WOULD ASSIST
EMPLOYEES AND TRACKING THIS TYPE
OF WORK.
IT'S VERY UNIQUE AND NOT IT'S
NOT JUST TRANSACTIONAL SERVICES
THAT DC PROVIDES BUT ALSO POLICY
SUPPORT SO SEPARATE FROM OTHER.
STATE AGENCIES THAT DO YOU HAVE
A PRO RATA STRUCTURE.
THERE YOU KNOW ANALYZING POLICY
ANALYZING BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS AS OPPOSED TO JUST
TRANSACTIONAL SUCH AS HUMAN
RESOURCES AND BUDGETING
TRANSACTIONAL SERVICES.
THE LAST POINT THAT I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT TRACKING THE DATA
FROM ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT IT MAY
POSSIBLY PRODUCE SKEWED DATA.
AS YOU KNOW POLICY CHANGES THAT
PRIORITIES CHANGE ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS AND SO WHERE THERE MAY BE.
A LOT OF POLICY EMPHASIS IN ONE
SPECIFIC BORDER BUREAU IN ONE
YEAR IT MIGHT IT MAY BE QUIET
THE FOLLOWING YEAR AND SO IT
WOULD BE REALLY DIFFICULT TO.
SUBSTANTIATE THIS DATA AND
PROVIDE SOMETHING THAT'S VIABLE
FOR US TO EVALUATE TO PRODUCE
THE.
THE ANSWERS THAT.
THE LA EL AND AND.
WOULD BE LOOKING FOR THE GOING
BACK TO STATEMENT YOU THINK IT'S
A HORRIBLE RIGHT NOW THE WAY IT
IS.
WE DO THINK THAT THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE IS EQUITABLE AND
PROVIDES A GUARANTEE OF THE
SERVICE IS BEING DISTRIBUTED
RIGHT WING REPORTED IT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE THAT HORRIBLE AND.
PESSIMISM MEASURE YET THINGS
CHANGE FROM YEAR TO YEAR BUT
SOME METHODOLOGY TO MEASURE
WHAT.
SOME IS BEING CHARGED.
AND IN THE BEST ZIP LIKE GIVE A
REFER SOME WERE YOU KNOW THE
COUNTY.
S. CHARGING TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO BUILD A POLICE CAR.
AND YET SOMEONE ELSE COULD
DELIVER TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
SO IT'S JUST.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE TO PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE AS THEY GO BUT. NOT
BE OVER CHARGED ON THAT'S I MEAN
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS AND
IT SHOULD BE A BETTER MECHANISM
TO TRACK.
THESE COST AND WE DO UNDERSTAND.
THAT CONCERN TOTALLY.
.
WE YOU KNOW HOW I NOTED THAT.
THE MOST OF THOSE SERVICES ARE
TRAPPED BY USAGE BUT THE
REMAINING THAT ARE DIFFICULT TO
DO SUCH I'M TRACKING.
ARE DONE WITH THE BEST
METHODOLOGY THAT WE FEEL IS
APPLICABLE TO ACROSS THE BOARD.
WHOSE INTEGRAL STATE OBVIOUSLY
GOT MOVED FOR A REASON AND IT
REALLY STANDS OUT.
SO.
WHO A GOOD QUESTION ONCE
APPEARED THE NEW DEPARTMENT OF
REAL ESTATE?
ABOUT THE SAME LEVEL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES.
FOR SELF AT A LOWER PRICE THAN
THE CA TO PROVIDE SIMILAR
SERVICES.
I A PROVIDED A HANDOUT THAT.
WAS PASSED OUT JUST A FEW
MOMENTS AGO THAT WALKS THROUGH
THE BREAKOUT OF. THE ESTIMATED
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
OF WHAT BREED WOULD BE PAYING
FOR THEIR PRO RATA NEXT YEAR
SHOULD THEY HAVE STAINED.
AND I CAN WALK THROUGH EACH OF
THOSE ROSE IF YOU LIKE BUT. I
THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS.
AND WHAT MAKES IT'S DIFFICULT
IS THAT PRES CURRENT REQUEST FOR
ON GOING STAFFING DOESN'T
PERFECTLY ALIGNED WITH THE CA
SERVICES ON A ONE TO ONE BASIS
BECAUSE A LOT OF SERVICES ARE
STAND ALONE SERVICES THAT
REQUIRE.
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT WHETHER
OR NOT THERE ARE THIRTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE OR FORTY FOUR TWO
BUREAUS.
ADDITIONALLY THEORY HAS SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN HOUSE.
BEFORE JOINING THE CA PRE
CONTRACTED FOR SOME SERVICES
THAT THEY PRESUMABLY WILL
CONTRACT FOR AGAIN ONCE THE EXIT
AND THOSE HAVEN'T BEEN ACCOUNTED
FOR.
ALSO.
TO SAYS WITH ANY DEPARTMENT THAT
STARTING OUT OR AT ANY POINT
DURING THE BUDGET YEAR IF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE NEEDED.
PRE HAS THE ABILITY TO ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THROUGH THE
BCP PROCESS.
SO.
THEY MAY FIND THAT AS THEY GO
ALONG THEY ARE NOT CORRECTLY
RESOURCE.
.
REMAINING DCA STAFF WILL BE
REDIRECTED TO ASSIST OTHER PORTS
AND BUREAUS AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF NON JURISDICTIONAL WORKLOAD
FUNCTIONS LIKE WHAT I WAS
ALLUDING TO A MOMENT AGO THAT
HAVE TO BE. SERVICED AND PAID
FOR AT DCA.
AN EXAMPLE WOULD BE OUR PHONE
BANKS OR OUR.
EXECUTIVE TEAM WHO PRESUMABLY
WORK ON POLICY REGARDLESS OF HOW
MANY PORTS ARE BUREAUS ARE
UNDERNEATH THEM.
I AM.
ADDITIONALLY DCA MAINTAINS A
BASIC LEVEL OF CENTRO I SERVICES
TO ACCOMMODATE WORKLOAD SPIKES
THAT ARE NOT IT ANTICIPATED OR
BUDGET IT. SO AN EXAMPLE WOULD
BE THAT OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
D. C. A. S. CLOWN CENTRO I STAFF
TO KEEP THE BOARD. OF VOCATIONAL
NURSES IN PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS AFLOAT. AND ALSO WE
HAVE PROVIDED.
ADDITIONAL DCA CENTRALIZED
SERVICES TO ON FORWARD.
HOUSEHOLD GOOD MOVERS TO BEAR
HEFTY  TAUGHT BUBBLES
WORKLOAD SPIKE SO WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THAT SPIKE IS NOT THERE.
OBVIOUSLY YOU STILL.
CARING THOSE FOLKS SO RIGHT SO
ARE OUR CURRENT METHODOLOGY IN
THE WAY PRO RATA WORKS IS IT'S
BUILT ON AVERAGES SO IT ASSUMES
THAT. EVERY POSITION MATS AND A
BORDER BUREAU REQUIRES A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT ON AVERAGE.
SO LIKE WHEN YOU GET IN A
POSITION THAT POSITION NEEDS TO
BE HIRED THERE'S PAPERWORK AND I
AND TERMS OF HIRING OPPOSITION
GIVING THEM A PAYCHECK. ANY
PERSONNEL TRANSACTIONS GETTING
THEM RESOURCES AND BUDGETS
I T. SUPPORT THAT'S NEEDED FOR
THAT INDIVIDUALS TASK AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON THEY HAVE A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF. OF OVERSIGHT
MY I GET THAT BUT RIGHT SINGLES
WITH SPIKES
WE HAD LIKE SINCE YOU KNOW
THERE'S THAT THERE'S AN EXTRA
DEMAND LOAD FOR WORK RADICALLY
ASSUME THAT DEMAND.
SO WHAT IT WHATEVER IT MAY BE
SILICON INTO SUMA INTERNALLY.
THEN.
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT THERE ALL THE
TIME WHERE THEY DO THE REST THE
TIME NOW WORKLOAD IS DOWN BY
PULLING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERSIGHT. FOR ALL THE PORTS AND
HEROES WERE ABLE TO PRODUCE
EFFICIENCIES IN TERMS OF OUR
COST BEING GENERALLY LOWER BUT
IT ALSO SERVES AS A WAY TO
BALANCE.
THE PEAKS AND VALLEYS OF THE
THIRTY PORTS AND BUREAUS SO. AND
ALL THE SYSTEM WORKS IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR ONE BORDER BUREAU MAY
PICK UP A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
ANOTHER BUT. AS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WAS INDICATED THAT'S NOT
CONSISTENT YEAR OVER YEAR AND
SEWER ONE BOARD OR BUREAU ME
PEAK.
AND.
BYPASSED EUROPEAN IT MAY BE A
DIFFERENT STORY IN THE NEXT YEAR
BUT OVER TIME IT SEEMS TO BE THE
MOST EFFICIENT WAY TO ALLOCATE
CENTRO I SERVICES AND SOMETHING
THAT'S USE WIDESPREAD. AMONG
MANY MANY DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION SO OPPOSITION THE
FUNCTIONS WILL BE ELIMINATED AS
A RESULT OF THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER PROPOSAL. THAT FOR THE
REDUCES DCA CENTRALIZED
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES.
AND WE ARE ACTUALLY WORKING ON
TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT WE ARE
SOLICITING INFORMATION FROM A
WORK GROUP. ADAM SO WE HAVE
INVITED FORWARD AND BUREAU STAFF
TO TIME ASSIST US AND WHAT A
SNOW THERE.
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ITEMS THAT
WE COULD REDUCE OR ELIMINATE IN
THE FUTURE YEARS SO WE'RE TRYING
TO FIND CONSISTENT MESSAGES WITH
WHAT WILL THEY WOULDN'T LIKE TO
SEE OUR RESOURCES. PILOTED
TOWARD AND IF WE NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AYE IN THE ONGOING
YEARS THEN WE WILL BRING THEM TO
THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE BCP
PROCESS OF THAT. ADDITIONAL
STAFF CAN BE VETTED AT THAT TIME
AND AND ON A MORE FOCUSED BASIS
INCOMES IN THE COMMITTEE.
NICHOLAS THE PUBLIC.
GOING CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT THAT
THEY SHOULD BE TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT HOW MUCH BOARDS AND GIRLS
ARE BEING CHARGED FOR DC
SERVICES.
AND HOW MUCH OF SERVICES THEY
USE COMPARED TO OTHERS.
LEGISLATORS LEFT WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS PROPOSAL TO SEE
IF THERE'S AN APPROACH THAT WILL
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY. WHEN ALL
THIS ITEM OPEN.
SALUTE OUR FILE ITEM WHICH IS
THE.
BREEZE SYSTEM
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALAN HONOR
WITH THE DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU REGARDING THE
DEPARTMENT'S BCP TO SUPPORT FREE
SYSTEM MAINTENANCE.
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS IS
REQUESTING APPROPRIATION
AUTHORITY.
STEAM POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN TWENTY FOR THE SUPPORT
OF PRES MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS.
APPROVAL OF THIS REQUEST WILL
ENSURE THAT THE EXISTING STATE
CIVIL SERVICE RESOURCES AND
STRATEGICALLY DECREASING VENDOR
RESOURCES CAN CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE BOARD IN HEROES WHO
USED TO PRE SYSTEM. TO CONDUCT
DATED A BUSINESS ACTIVITIES.
FOR CONTEXT IN FISCAL YEAR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION IN FUNDING TO SUPPORT
PRES MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS.
AS IDENTIFIED IN SECTION EIGHT
OF THE BCP.
ASIDE FROM MAKING ITS OPERATIONS
FUNDING FUNDING IN THE AMOUNT OF
THREE POINT THREE MILLION IS
BEING REQUESTED TO PAY THE
CREDIT CARD PROCESSING FEES THAT
ARE INCURRED WHEN SOMEBODY
APPLIES ONLINE TO THE SYSTEM.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE
ON THIS REQUEST ELLIOTT.
WE HAVE THEIR CONCERNS FINANCE
I THINK OUT INCLUSIVELY
COMMITTEE.
IF YOU
THANK YOU OF YOUR BACK.
A I THINK WHEN WE WERE ALL
ASPECTS HERE WE STARTED A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS BEING
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A.
PROJECT THAT HAD TAKEN MUCH
LONGER THAN WE EXPECTED AND JUST
TO PROVIDE A LITTLE CONTEXT HER
COLLEAGUES I KNOW IN. TWO
THOUSAND NINE WHEN IT WAS
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
ESSENTIALLY TRIPLED. AND.
HAS TAKEN A LONG TIME SO A
COUPLE QUESTIONS WHAT IS THE
TOTAL BUDGET AT THIS POINT IT
WAS NOT IN THE.
THE TOTAL BUDGET FOR THE PROJECT
AND SO I DON'T HAVE IT WOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THE PEER WHICH WAS
SUBMITTED.
I BELIEVE LAST YEAR NAM AS THE
PROJECT FACES BEEN A CLOSED OUT
THIS FUNDING IS FOR MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS OF THE EIGHTEEN
EXISTING BOARDS AND BUREAUS
WOULD CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP WITH
THAT INFORMATION ON THE TOTAL
TOTAL PROJECT TRYING TO GET BIG
PICTURE. ACTIVITY GARCIA
DEPARTMENT FINANCE I NINETY FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION POINT FIVE
OKAY ASSERTIVE AND WHAT WAS
PURPORTED ON THE PIER. GOTCHA
AND AT THIS POINT THERE EIGHTEEN
PORTS AND BUREAUS THAT USE PRE
SOMEHOW ANYMORE STILL NEED TO
COME ON.
SIXTEEN SIXTEEN AND WHAT'S THE
PLAN FOR THAT.
OF THE PLAN FOR THAT IS
ENCAPSULATED IN OUR BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION OTHERS LIKE ME TO
GO INTO A LITTLE DETAIL CURRENT
LOVE TO HEAR THAT AND ARE. IN NO
LATE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AFTER
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTING IN
STABILIZING BREEZE RELEASED TO.
US I'M SORRY JASON WHICH ONLY
DEPARTMENT OF.
CONSUMER AFFAIRS PRIVILEGE ICE.
THE DEPARTMENT TURNED ITS FOCUS
TO RELEASED THREE THE SIXTEEN
PROGRAMS THAT EUROPE OF.
ENQUIRING ABOUT OVER THE FIRST
QUARTER OF A FIRST THREE
QUARTERS OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPED A STRUCTURED
METHODOLOGY FOR THE RELEASE
THREE. PROGRAMS
EXCUSE ME. PROGRAM TO DOCUMENT
ANALYZE. AND CHOOSE AN
APPROPRIATE AND COST EFFECTIVE
REPLACEMENT FOR THEIR LEGACY
SYSTEMS.
WE DEVELOPED THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN A SINGLE
DOCUMENT.
OUTLINING STRUCTURE AND GUARD
RAILS FOR THE RELEASE THREE
PROGRAMS
WE ALSO DEVELOPED SIXTEEN
DIFFERENT BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
REPORTS.
AN INDIVIDUALIZED DOCUMENT
SPECIFIC TO EACH PROGRAM.
THESE REPORTS INCLUDED INITIAL
ANALYSIS OF THE PROGRAM'S
OVERALL READINESS.
AND INTRODUCTION TO CHANGE
MANAGEMENT AND PROPOSED
SCHEDULES.
THE PLAN IN SIXTEEN REPORTS WERE
DELIVERED TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES IN DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
THE FIRST STEP OF THE
MODERNIZATION PLANS TO DOCUMENT
ALL BUSINESS PROCESSES TO
DETERMINE SPECIFIC BUSINESS
FUNCTION REQUIREMENTS.
FIVE PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY
ENGAGED IN THESE ACTIVITIES.
YOU'RE OF BOARD OF PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY BOARD OF
CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY AND THE
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD.
THE NEXT STEP IN THE PROCESS IS
THE PAL PROCESS THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE WHICH IS
REQUIRED APPROVAL PROCESS THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
CURRENTLY ONE PROGRAM THE BOARD
OF PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IS IN
THE PAL PROCESS HAS SUBMITTED
AND A.
AND HAS GAINED APPROVAL FOR THE
STAGE ONE OF THE POWER PROCESS.
AND THREE OTHERS ARE CURRENTLY
DRAFTING AND OF GOING TO SUBMIT
IN THE NEAR FUTURE STAGE ONE OF
THE POWER PROCESS THOSE ARE
BUREAU FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS. AND THE
FIDUCIARY BUREAU.
VIS AD IF I I DON'T KNOW IF I
MENTIONED IT BUT A LOT
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS COMPLETED
IT THE STAGE ONE BUSINESS AND
HOUSES FOR PAL. HAS ACHIEVED.
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY APPROVAL
AND IS.
SOON GOING TO SUBMIT STAGE TWO
OF THAT POWER PROCESS.
OTHER ELAINE LATELY JUST CERTAIN
ARE UP BUT I JUST TO LOVE FEEDER
JUST BREAK IT DOWN INTO.
NUMBER CRADDICK ENGLISH SO WE'VE
SIXTEEN APARTMENTS LEFT HOW LONG
IT'S IT GONNA TAKE TO GET ALL
THOSE UP ON BREEZE.
I'M HEARING DIFFERENT STAGES OF
THINGS AND. DIFFERENT ACRONYMS
AND AND DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
AND DIFFERENT FACES BUT WHAT IS
THIS WHAT IS THIS MADE FOR ONE
IT'S GONNA GET OUT.
THE PROPOSED SCHEDULE SPAN.
IMPLEMENTATION BETWEEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR.
OKAY SO IT'LL IT'LL TAKE SIX
MORE YEARS TO GET THE REMAINING
EIGHTEEN UP ONBOARD.
SO THIS PROJECT STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE.
SO WE'LL TAKE THIRTEEN YEARS TO
GET THIS PROJECT DONE.
THIS PROJECT OF BEING A
SEPARATE PROJECT FROM THE
INITIAL BREEZE. AND OF THIS
SCHOOL THE INITIAL PRES WAS
SUPPOSED TO CAPTURE ALL
DEPARTMENTS UNDER THE SEA HAS
AUTHORITY RIGHT CORRECT AFTER TO
FIT JANUARY TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT NUMBER
THREE A THREE POINT ONE. OF
REMOVED THOSE EIGHTEEN AT THAT
TIME SIXTEEN NOW PROGRAMS FROM
THE PROJECT.
REMOVE HIM BECAUSE IT WAS JUST
TOO HARD.
REMOVED BECAUSE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT RELEASED ONE
BROUGHT. AND.
.
DECISION MAKERS FELT THAT THAT
WAS APPROVED IN A DECISION TO
MAKE AT THE TIME.
OKAY.
AND HOW MUCH ARE WE EXPECTED TO
SPEND ON THIS BETWEEN NOW AND
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR V. A
DOLLARS WILL BE VETTED THROUGH
THE FAW IS FISCAL ANALYSIS
WORKSHEETS.
WITHIN THE PAL PROCESS STAGE
TWO OF THE POWER PROCESS WE
DON'T KNOW.
DO NOT OKAY WHAT'S YOUR GUESS.
I COULDN'T HAVE HAD A CONCERT SO
I I RAISES QUESTIONS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A PROJECT THAT
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
TWENTY MILLION WERE NOW AT
NINETY.
IT'S MILLION WERE HALFWAY DONE
OR NOT TO BE FINISHED UNTIL ALL
OF US GET TURNED OUT OF OFFICE
CLOSE TO IT.
I'M I. I KNOW I SOUND LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD COLLEAGUES I'M
JUST.
TRYING TO GET A HANDLE OF HOW WE
GET A BETTER HANDLE ON THESE
PROJECTS I'M LOOKING AT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF LOOKING
AT ALEJO.
.
IF YOU HAVE ANY SUGGESTIONS
WOULD LOVE THEM I COULD JUST
CONTINUE EVERY TIME ONE OF THESE
MAJOR PROJECTS COME THROUGH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT I'M GETTING
CLOSE TO THE POINT WHERE I MAY
START VOTING AGAINST THESE
PROJECTS I JUST WANNA.
WANT TO SAY THAT BECAUSE IT IT
IT JUST IT IT'S IT'S TESTING THE
PATIENCE OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
CERTAINLY IT MAY.
I I I APPRECIATE THAT.
IN JUST TO.
YOU SAID.
REMOVE THE BUREAUCRATIC SPEAK.
I AM VERY HAPPY TO DO THAT THE
BUSINESS MONETIZATION STRUCTURE
THAT WE PUT IN PLACE FOR THE
REMAINING SIXTEEN PROGRAMS. IS
THE PATH FORWARD TO SUCCESSFUL
IT IMPLEMENTATION EARLY SIGNS
WITH THE BUSINESSES SPECIFICALLY
HAVE SHOWN.
GREAT SUCCESS GREAT ADOPTION
EARLY STAGES MIND YOU.
BUT SAID THE THREE PROGRAMS
THAT WE'VE GOT TAKEN THROUGH
BUSINESS ACTIVITIES HAVE SHOWN.
A ENGAGEMENT LEVEL THAT IS VERY
HIGH AS WELL AS IT.
EXCITEMENT LEVEL MIGHT SOUND A
LITTLE OFF BUT AND EXCITEMENT
LEVEL BECAUSE THEY'RE
IDENTIFYING THEIR BUSINESS
PROCESSES LIKE HAVING DONE IN
THE PAST AND THEY'RE REALIZING
EFFICIENCIES.
AND THEY'RE REALIZING A PATHWAY
FOR TO A SUCCESSFUL IT
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH BEGINS WITH
KNOWING THEIR BUSINESS I'M I
HAVE SEVERAL QUOTES ON THAT I
WILL READ TO YOU BUT
TESTIMONIALS FROM THE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH. SO FAR.
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS.
AS WELL AS THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY THAT FULLY
SUPPORT THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PROCESS SO I.
AGREE WITH YOUR FRUSTRATION.
I AGREE WITH YOUR UP THAT
SENTIMENT ABOUT PIC PATIENTS.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE FOUND
THE PATH FORWARD TO SUCCESS WHY
TEAM IMPLEMENTATION WITH THE
REMAINING SIXTEEN PROGRAMS.
THE TIME AND.
.
DOES SEEM WILL EXTEND OUT AND WE
BELIEVE THAT TIME WILL BE WELL
SPENT WITH THE PATH THAT WE SET
OUT.
IS THERE ANY WAY TO PULL THAT
TIME FRAME OF SIX YEARS.
SELECT TO YOU I MEAN AGAIN WE
HAVE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES THAT ARE LOOKING.
TO. GET HELPED BY.
STATE ON THIS SO THAT IF THERE'S
A REASON YOU'RE YOU'RE
OBVIOUSLY.
INTERACTING WITH JUST FIVE OF
THE SIXTEEN UNITS FOR NOW RIGHT
NEXT TWO YEARS YOU'RE
ESSENTIALLY DOING THEM THAT WAY
AS OPPOSED TO TRYING TO. CORRECT
TACKLE THEM TOGETHER AND SO I
THINK YOU'RE ASK BY CONTRACT IN
THE TIME FRAME IS IT POSSIBLE.
BUT OF COURSE EVERYTHING IS PUT
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE WHAT WE
WOULD ARE REALLY FOCUSING ON IS
THE ORGANIZATIONAL READINESS
WERE LOOKING AT EACH BOREDOM
BUREAU TALKING WITH THEIR
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS. THEIR BOARD
MEMBER THEIR BOARD LEADERSHIP AS
WELL AS OUR STAFF TO SAY CAN YOU
SUPPORT THIS PROJECT.
FISCALLY STAFF AND.
THE TIME COMMITMENT REQUIRED
AND IF THEY ARE AT ALL SAY NO
THEN WE KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE OBSTACLES IN BRICK WALLS
THAT WHEN WRITING TO DOWN THE
LINE.
SO WE WORK WITH THEM TO GET
THEM MORE ORGANIZATIONALLY READY
LIKE I SAID THE EARLY ADOPTERS
THE FIVE OR SO THAT I RAN OFF.
THEY WE WENT THROUGH WITH
CHANGE MANAGEMENT WE WENT
THROUGH WHAT TO EXPECT.
DURING A PROJECT LIKE THIS AND
AFTER THAT THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THERE WERE STILL EAGER IT TO
COMMIT THE RESOURCES TO MOVE
FORWARD. AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SEEING EARLY SUCCESSES WITH THIS
CONTRACTING THE TIME SCHEDULE.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO TRY TO FIGHT
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO CONTRACT THE
TIME SCHEDULE.
WOULD REQUIRE RESOURCES AT THIS
TIME THAT I'M I'M UNAWARE OF AND
THE ORGANIZATIONAL READINESS
ACTS ASPECT IS OF COURSE. IN THE
BOREDOM BUREAU ARENA.
.
SO I'D BE HAPPY TO LOOK AT THAT
FOR YOU AND IF I UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY ARE.
DOLLARS TO HELP WITH SUPPORT IN
THE MAINTENANCE OF THE OPERATION
ONGOING.
SO IS THIS THE LEVEL OF ONGOING
EXPENDITURES WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
BE SPENDING SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS NEXT YEAR.
EXCEPT TRY OUT INTO THE FUTURE
IT IT'S A IT'S A GRADUAL DECLINE
YEAH THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT REACHES ITS BASELINE. AND
ON OF FIVE POINT SEVEN. THAT
IRAQ WAIT SEVEN MILLION. AND
THAT IS SIMPLY FOR SOFTWARE
LICENSING WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT WILL EXIST FOR.
AS LONG AS WE REALIZE A SYSTEM
AND STATE P. WISE TO SUPPORT
THAT SYSTEM.
THAT.
DECLINE COMES AS WE ARE.
.
DECREASING.
CONTRACT WORK
I AM TAKING ON.
MORE OF THE WORK OURSELVES IF
THE STATE STAFF WHICH THAT LINE
HAS GONE UP OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS.
SEAN CAN YOU SHARE ANY
STATISTICS IN THAT AREA SHARON
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN OF THE OVERALL
SYSTEM CHANGES THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED AS REQUESTED BY THE
BOARDS AND BUREAUS USING BREEZE.
FORTY FIVE PERCENT AND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN WERE DONE EXCLUSIVELY BY
STATE STAFF I IN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THAT NUMBER ROSE TO
SIXTY TWO PERCENT. WE LOOKED AT
A NUMBER ON.
JUST EARLIER THIS MONTH AND
READ ABOUT SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT
THIS FISCAL YEAR FOR TOTAL
NUMBER OF SYSTEM CHANGES DONE
ENTIRELY BY STATE STOP WITHOUT
CONTRACTOR VENDOR RESOURCES.
OKAY BUT AND AND WE DON'T AGAIN
HAVE A BUDGET OF WHAT IT'S GOING
TO TAKE TO GET THE LAST SIXTEEN.
BOARDS APPEARS UP AND RUNNING
BUT WE DO HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
SENSE WHAT THE ONGOING COSTS ARE
GOING TO BE.
CHAU GOING TOTAL TOTAL OPERATING
AND MAINTENANCE DOLLARS.
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FORTY OF A
SENSE OF WHAT THAT'S GOING TO
BE.
I BELIEVE THAT OUTLINED IN TABLE
THREE OF THE OF THAT PAGE THREE
OF THE VCP IN TABLE THREE WE
ARE.
WE PUT TOGETHER THE THE LEVEL
OF FUNDING FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY ARE WE DON'T
HAVE IN FRONT OF US SORRY.
WE HAVE THAT TABLE IT'S I JUST
READ IN THE YEAH SURE SO FLOWER
ON TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH IS IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE AMOUNTS I
MENTIONED. NINE POINT THREE
MILLION TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
EIGHT POINT FOUR AND INTO THE
BASELINE LEVEL OF FIVE POINT
SEVEN SO WHAT'S THAT TOTAL OR IF
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE
OF.
WHAT WE LEVEL OF SPENT BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR MINUS THE
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS FOR THE
NUMBERS YOU DON'T KNOW?
YOU MEAN THAT INDIVIDUAL LINE
ITEMS YEAH.
TWENTY SIX.
TWENTY SIX MILLION IF ONLY SIX
MILLION OF ASSETS TWENTY SIX
MILLION ON TOP OF WAS NINETY SIX
MILLION.
WHICH IS HOW MUCH IT COSTS OR
TALK IN A HUNDRED AND.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR BREEZE
PROJECT THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
COST TWENTY.
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
ON I HIGH RAISES I'M NOT REALLY
SURE I JUST KEEP I KEEP RAISING
THIS I'M NOT. YOU KNOW AT SOME
POINT MAYBE I GET TIRED OF IT
BUT I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT TO
OUR COLLEAGUES AT. THE SIR THESE
ARE BUDGET EXPENDITURES THAT.
IF WE KNEW IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE THOSE
DECISIONS WOULD HAVE BEEN MADE
AND AND FRANKLY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE SITTING HERE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. I'M WONDERING
WHETHER WE WANT TO COMMIT TO
THESE TYPES OF DOLLARS THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. ONE A NUMBER
OF US.
YOU KNOW.
WILL BE OUR TENTH OR TWELFTH
YEAR. ARM I DON'T HAVE ANY
ANSWERS.
ONE QUESTION ONE THING I WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST OF STAFF IF
POSSIBLE IN THE BACKGROUND.
FUTURE.
IF IF IT'S POSSIBLE TO PUT JUST
A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT
FOR THESE PROJECTS BECAUSE I
THINK THE SUMMARY THAT WE HAVE.
GIVES A A SNAPSHOT OF EXACTLY
WHERE WE ARE TODAY BUT DOESN'T
TELL US WHAT THE LONGEVITY IS.
BUT.
CLEARLY FROM ONE PERSPECTIVE
SIDE.
WE'RE NOT DOING SOMETHING RIGHT
AND I I'M I'M NOT SURE WE DO
NEXT BUT I WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE
TO ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT.
WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO TACKLE
THESE LARGE IT PROJECTS YOU HAVE
HURT ME. A TALK ABOUT THIS EVERY
TWO WEEKS WITH ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT WITH ANOTHER LARGE IT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IMPLEMENTATION.
THE ELF ALSO MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS I DON'T HAVE MUCH STATE
IN MUCH FAITH IN THE STATE I
TEAM. BECAUSE WE COME.
PROJECT AFTER PROJECT THAT'S
OVER COST OVERRUN IN THIS
DOESN'T REALLY GIVE CHIU
SNAPSHOT. WAS OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WHEN I FIRST
STARTED IN IN WE TURN OUT IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE THIRD OF OUR
WAY THROUGH THIS STILL WILL NOT
BE DONE.
AND THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
SUBSTITUTING IT IT'S A IT'S A
WASTE OF MONEY IT'S YOU KNOW IF
THIS WAS.
A PRIVATE BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW I JUST.
WE WE CAN FUNCTION.
AND IT'S JUST IT'S AS IF IT BEST
IS DYSFUNCTIONAL.
YOU KNOW SO I I.
I'M FRUSTRATED WHEN WE'RE ALL
FRUSTRATED APPEARED I AGREED
LIKELY WE SHOULDN'T BOTH THESE
PROJECTS.
AT SOME POINT AND WE'RE GONNA BE
HERE FOR A WHILE STILL SO. WE
STOPPED RUNNING IT.
MR SHAPIRO.
ACTUALLY I'M NOT PROBABLY BRINGS
IT BUT A GOOD SUBJECT FOR A
HEARING IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE FOR
US TO HAVE.
THAT THE.
TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT COME AND
TALK TO US ABOUT HOW THEY'VE
CHANGED THE PROCUREMENT METHOD.
BECAUSE THIS PROCUREMENT METHOD
WAS THE OLD METHOD.
THAT WAS UTILIZED WHICH IS YOU
OUGHT YOU FIGURED OUT.
.
IT'S IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A METHOD
WHERE YOU USE YOU SAY HERE'S
WHAT WE KNOW. SO WE'RE GONNA BY
WHAT WE KNOW. AND THEN YOU GET
BIDS FOR THAT. AND THEN.
.
IT TAKES IT'S IT IT'S AT LEAST A
THREE YEAR PROCESS TO PUT THEM
TO BED THAT ARE OF PIECE
TOGETHER TO GO OUT TO GET THE
BIDS IN AND RUN IT THROUGH. THE
WAY THAT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DEALS WITH THAT SO THAT WEEK
THAT LEGISLATURE GETS
INFORMATION. AND SO BY THE TIME
THE LEGISLATURE'S IS PUTTING THE
STAMP OF APPROVAL THE PROJECT
HAS BEEN. IN OPERATION FOR LIKE
FOUR YEARS SOME BUT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT AND THEN THEY START
BUILDING IT.
AND.
AND THE CHALLENGE IS IT THAT IT
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS ALREADY OLD
NUMBER ONE. IT'S UNKNOWN
TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS AVAILABLE
FIVE YEARS BEFORE AND SO TO THE
TECHNOLOGY HAS CHANGED.
AND SO ON AND. AND FRANKLY.
IN THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT A BIG
PART OF THE PROBLEM WAS THAT
EACH BOARD.
HAD TO DETERMINE WHAT CHANGES
THEY WOULD MAKE IN THEIR PROCESS
SEIZE IN ORDER FOR THE FOR THEM
TO THEN GIVE ADVICE.
TO THE DEVELOPERS OF THE OF THE
PLATFORM FOR THEIR BOARD. AND
THEY IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO KNOW WHAT PROCESS SEES IT
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE SKILL SETS
TO TO KNOW AND SO WE WERE WEIRD
IT'S LIKE WE'RE DEALING WITH.
WITH FORTY DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN THIS SO.
THE PROCESSES CHANGED I KNOW
IT'S CHANGED I CAN'T DESCRIBE IT
TO YOU BECAUSE IT'S TECHNOLOGY
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE WILL BE
BUYING UNDER THAT SYSTEM ANY
LONGER AND SO WOULD BE GOOD FOR
US TO HAVE.
I PRESENTATION SO WE CAN SEE
WHAT IT IS THAT THAT THE NEW
SYSTEM ENTAILS BECAUSE I AGREE
WITH YOU IT IS FRUSTRATING YOU
LOOK AT IT IT IT DIDN'T. OUT
WORK WELL FOR MANY OF THE OF THE
BOARDS BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T DO
THE ADVANCE PLANNING AND THEY
JUST BASICALLY SAID HERE'S OUR
PROCESSES.
THERE TWENTY FIVE STEPS TO GET
LICENSING AND SO WE'RE JUST
CREATE THOSE TWENTY FIVE STEPS
ON THE COULD HAVE REDONE THEIR.
THEIR PROCESS AND HAVE HAD SOME
EFFICIENCY NOT AGREEING GOING
FOR LEASE IT PROJECTS WE SHOULD
HAVE A.
A BETTER SNAPSHOT OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE ENTIRE PROCESS
FROM DAY ONE THROUGH EMAIL
BECAUSE IT WISE WE.
THE US WERE ASKING WHERE A
SINGLES OLD BCP'S.
THAT'S OVER A MILLION NOW SO
LESSEN MY AGATHA BB REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE FOR FUTURE.
I TO PROJECTS TO KNOW HOW MUCH
WE'RE INTO IT. AND AND I JUST
THINK THAT IT'S IT'S BETTER IF
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT.
THAT THE PROCUREMENT THE RFP.
THE REASON THAT WE DO IT THAT
WAY OR DID IT THAT WAY IT IT
WORKS REALLY GOOD FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT BUT DOESN'T
WORK REAL GOOD FOR AN IT PROJECT
AND. THE CHALLENGES THAT THE
REASON THAT WE DO IT THAT WAY SO
THAT EVERYBODY GETS TO SEE WHAT
THAT HIGH BID IS OR THE LOW BID
I'M SORRY. AND YOU CAN LOOK AT
APPLES TO
APPLES TO ORANGES AND.
TO DO I KEY PROJECTS THAT WE DID
THAT MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME SURE.
SO THERE'S NO COMMENTS WERE
HOLES ITEM OPEN.
DOCTOR CHOI.
THERE REALLY ARE FRUSTRATING TO
HEAR THAT YOU KNOW COST WISE I
AM AND THE MESSED MESSIAH SO
WRONG AND I EACH YEAR.
THE OPERATING COST CLOSE UP BOMB
IN THE PROCUREMENT OF CLOSE
CLOSE UP BUT. I WONDER IF WHAT
THIS US OFF TO A SLOW OR DEVELOP
THE IN HOUSE SO WHAT DO YOU GO
OUTSIDE LIKE A PROCUREMENT
THROUGH UPDATING.
AND AND AT THE SAME TIME THE
NUMBER OF WILL USE THAT MEMBERS
ARE OF YOU KNOW GROWING FORTY
THREE PERCENT DAILY. POSITIONS
SO YOU ARE REQUESTING HERE.
AND AND THIS IS I DON'T HAVE A
MUCH BACKGROUND ON HOW A NEW
OPERATIONS SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO
ME. THIS UNNECESSARY AYE TO SELF
TO HEAR AS YOU'VE LA TRY TO.
TO UPDATE THE IS IT INTERNAL
DEVELOPMENT.
OR OR IT IS IT'S A POWER P.
THAT THE U. QUARK DEFENDERS.
SO.
AT THE TIME OF THE.
PROJECTS PHASE OF THE BREACH OF
PRES.
WE PROCURED A COMMERCIAL OFF
THE SHELF SYSTEMS SO IT'S A
SYSTEM THAT IS DESIGNED ON AND
BUILT TO DO.
ENFORCEMENT AND LICENSING
BUSINESS PROCESSES FOR.
FOR ENTITIES SUCH AS THOSE THAT
USE IT WITHIN A DEPARTMENT TUMOR
FAIRS.
%
ITS CONFIGURABLE SO IT'S IT'S
NOT.
INTENDED TO BE CUSTOM CODED.
WE BROUGHT IN A SOLUTION VENDER
UM ACCENTURE TO CONFIGURE THE
SYSTEM DURING THE PROJECT PHASE.
THEY HAVE BEEN RETAINED AT A
LESSER LEVEL THROUGH THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
PHASE.
THE.
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW I QUOTED
SOME STEPS IN NUMBERS ABOUT.
THAT STATE STAFF.
HAVE BEEN INCREASING IN THEIR
CAPABILITY TO ENTIRELY MAIN
MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM ON OUR OWN
WHICH THAT IS THE.
THAT GOAL AND THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE TRENDING TOWARDS WITH ON
NEARLY EIGHTY PERCENT OF ALL THE
SYSTEM CHANGE REQUESTS
IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR BEING DONE
ENTIRELY BY STATE STAFF. ON THE
FORTY THREE POSITIONS ON THAT
YOU REFERENCED I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION THAT THOSE ARE. NOT
ADDITIONAL TO WHAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE WE ONLY RECEIVED FUNDING
FOR ONE BUDGET YEAR LAST YEAR SO
I'M WE ARE SIMPLY CONTINUING UMP
REQUESTING CONTINUING FUNDING OF
THIS FORTY THREE POSITIONS. ON
THAT WE THAT WE HAVE FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR.
ONCE YOU APPROVED PROCURE WORTH
A SYSTEM USES SOME AYE IT IS
THAT MAINTAINED A BY OUR
INTERNAL STAFF OR DO YOU.
A CONTRACT OUT THAT THOUGH
WHICHEVER THE SYSTEM THAT YOU
HAPPENED TO PURCHASE SAID THAT
THERE OUTSIDE OF VENDOR. THROUGH
CONTRACT FIVE USE A TENURE SAID
THEY'D DO THEY MAINTAIN.
ON THAT DETERMINATION WILL BE
MADE AS WE GO THROUGH THE.
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY IF A SOLUTION WAS
SELECTED THROUGH THAT PROCESS
SUCH AS PRES.
WE WOULD HAVE EXPERTISE IN
HOUSE AND WE WOULD LOOK AT THE
ABILITY TO UTILIZE THAT
EXPERTISE.
TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
CONSCIOUS.
CONTRACTOR RESOURCE THAT WOULD
BE.
BRING ONBOARD BUT THAT WOULD BE
DETERMINED THROUGH THE PROJECT
APPROVAL I MEAN MY AUTONOMOUS
INSIST THAT THOUGH WHATEVER THE
SYSTEM YOU HAPPEN TO CHOOSE TO
AND AND THEN THE. NUMBER WILL
APPEAR AT THE MAINTENANCE
APPEARING TO FIVE YEARS TEN
YEARS TWENTY YEARS. IN THE
CONTRACTING OUT THE LEFT AND THE
RESPONSE BUT MAINTAINING THEN
YOU DON'T HAVE TO INCREASE OUR
INTERNAL STAFF MEMBERS AND THE
COSTING. YOU KNOW BUDGET JUSTICE
OFTEN QUOTE COSCO'S CLOSE UP BY
YOU MAINTENANCE OF PEOPLE YOU
HAVE TO KEEP ON ADDING NEW
PEOPLE AND KEEP AND TRY TO TRAIN
THEM.
YOU KNOW IT DOES MAKE SENSE TO
ME.
I UNDERSTAND.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CLAIRE I'M
A NURSE I LIVE IN SOLANO COUNTY
AND AM. I WORKING ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND FACULTY ACOSTA EAST BAY. AN
ACID AND HOP UP QUICKLY ENOUGH
FOR THE PREVIOUS ITEM BUT THIS
HAS TO DO BOTH WITH THE BEER AND
WITHIN THE DCA. I'M SO RECENTLY
EFFECTIVE APRIL FIFTH THE BR
INCREASE LICENSING FEES QUITE
INEQUITABLE  AGAINST
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES AND NURSING
STUDENTS INTERESTED IN PUBLIC
HEALTH.
SO. MY COMMENT IS REALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE.
ILIO AMONG RECOMMENDATION ABOUT
REVIEWING AND THE.
THE MANNER IN WHICH THE PRODUCT
COSTS AND THE MANNER IN WHICH
THAT BR AND INCREASED FEES.
BECAUSE IT IS REALLY AN
EQUITABLE AND BASED ON A SURVEY
MY COLLEAGUES AND I DID THIS
PAST SIXTIES.
SIX PERCENT OF NURSING STUDENTS
ARE GOING TO BE INTERESTED IN
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES WILL CONTINUE IN
THEIR CAREER SO IT REALLY HAS
IMPLICATIONS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
OKAY.
WHEN ELSE.
OKAY PUBLIC COMMENT IS CLOSED.
THE FINAL QUESTION HOW LONG HAVE
THE TWO OF YOU BETTER AT DCA.
I'VE BEEN AT DCA SINCE.
IN MY CURRENT POSITION TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND.
MID.
THIRTEEN OCCUR IN A TWO
THOUSAND.
I'M IN MY CURRENT POSITION.
BLADES TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUT
WITH DCA SINCE ARE THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND WORKING AT A BOARDING
NONE MOVING INTO IT IN TWENTY
TEN I I ASK I HAVE GREAT FAITH
IN. YOUR NAY DIRECTOR OF AND
THAT BEING SAID I KNOW THAT
BUREAUCRACIES ARE SLOW TO MOVE.
AND.
AND THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT
HAVE. HAVE BEEN AROUND SINCE
BEFORE BOTH YOUR TIME.
THEY WILL PROBABLY MAYBE AROUND
AFTER TIME I JUST HAPPEN TO READ
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT WHICH WAS
UNBELIEVABLY SKATING ABOUT WHAT
WAS NOT HAPPENING. JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO AND IT'S UNCLEAR TO ME
WHAT KIND OF HEADWAY SPIN MADE
SO.
I I'M I'M SURE THAT THE TWO OF
YOU HERE MESSENGERS.
IT BUT.
BUT WE DO NEED TO GET A HANDLE
ON THIS.
OVER TIME IT'S MY PERSPECTIVE
WE ARE PROBABLY SPENDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE
SHOULD BE SPENDING ON ON
WASTEFUL IT PROJECTS AND.
AND.
.
THOSE OF US ON THIS SIDE OF THE
AISLE WE WILL KEEP REYES NET BUT
AT SOME POINT WE'VE GOTTA FIGURE
OUT WHERE THE RIVERS CAN HIT THE
ROAD AND HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I.
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS AND IDEAS
HOPEFULLY FROM SOME OF THE
OTHER.
OVERSIGHT AGENCIES IN FISCAL
AGENCIES AND WHAT WE CAN DO.
WITH ANALYSTS ARE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
THAT IS TODAY'S FINAL ITEM.
WE ARE NOW YOU'RE
.
YEAH.
YEAH I WASN'T I WASN'T ENTIRELY
SURE.
OKAY HAVE ALMOST DOUBLED. FROM
WHERE THEY ALL LIVED THROUGH.
OUT THE WORLD BY.
I WASN'T REALLY FAIRLY.
YEAH.
HAVE.
THEY TOOK